Guten Morgen, Khaleesi.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Sag mal, was ist eigentlich deine Lieblingsprimzahl?
Ja, eins. Lockbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 453 vom 17. Februar 2023.
Und ja, wir sind's. Ich bin wieder da und Khaleesi ist auch wieder da.
Wenn Linus vermisst, das tun wir alle, aber Linus ist gerade unabkömmlich und
hat Dinge zu tun und kann von daher leider gerade nicht so, wie er möchte.
Aber das werden wir alles überstehen.
Und genau, Und in der Zwischenzeit klären wir mathematische Realitäten.
Ja, ich wollte mich jetzt nicht blamieren, deswegen. Und wir stellen jetzt auch
irgendwie immer Zahlenfragen am Anfang der Sendung.
Ja, so machen wir das jetzt. Das muss jetzt einfach auch geklärt werden.
Ja, die Eins ist keine Primzahl, ja da wissen wir jetzt auch schon,
bevor ihr gleich wieder einen Kommentar schreibt.
Aber das ist auch eine reine Definitionssache, finde ich. Ich finde,
die Eins einfach so im Regen stehen zu lassen, ist auch ein bisschen...
Ist auch so ein bisschen... Weiß ich nicht. Mathematik hat einfach keine Empathie.
Ja, ich persönlich bevorzuge Fibonacci-Zahlen, aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Okay. Ja. Jo, na gut, dann würde ich vorschlagen, kümmern wir uns ums Feedback.
Gab ja wieder so einiges und ich finde das immer ganz gut, weil dann wird man ja belehrt.
Und das ist wichtig, weil wir wissen ja auch nicht alles. Mag euch jetzt ein
bisschen komisch rüber so, wie was Tim weiß nicht alles.
Warum höre ich denn überhaupt diesen Podcast?
Ja, ist aber so. Ja, also auch mir entgeht mal ein Detail und dir auch, Kalesi.
Ich weiß nicht, wer hat sich denn hier geäußert. Soll ich mal einen Kommentar
vorlesen von Max. Geht nämlich um Schweden.
Kalesi hat die generelle Mentalität der Schweden schon ganz gut zusammengefasst.
Dazu, was ist in Schweden gerade
innenpolitisch los. Schweden hat einen ziemlichen Rechtsruck erlebt,
aktuell eine konservative Minderheitsregierung, ganz grob schwarz-gelb bei uns,
toleriert von ganz rechts außen, Zucker-AfD bis noch etwas rechter,
bloß schon zweitgrößte Fraktionen hinter den Sozialdemokraten.
Außerdem haben sie in letzter Zeit ein großes Problem mit Bandenkriminalität.
Aktuell kommt es mehrmals die Woche zu Morden und Bombenanschlägen.
Hier ist die beste deutschsprachige Quelle, schöner Link, den haben wir dann auch in den Show Notes.
Das Thema war schon im Wahlkampf sehr dominant. Dass in der Gemengelage Sicherheit
und Ausweitung von Befugnissen der Behörden ein Thema sind, ist dann leider
nicht mehr so überraschend.
Ja, ich denke, das ist eine sehr wichtige Ergänzung. Passt ja irgendwie zu dieser
ganzen Rechtsruckgeschichte, die wir gerade generell beobachten.
Und mir graut es, ehrlich gesagt, schon vor den nächsten EU-Wahlen,
muss ich sagen, wenn ich das so lese.
Jetzt in Bezug auf Schweden oder in Bezug auf alle Länder?
In Bezug auf alle Länder. Also, na.
Ja, gut, das weiß man immer nicht so ganz genau. Was dann am Ende?
Wann ist überhaupt das nächste Mal wieder Europawahl? Nächstes Jahr?
Ach echt schon, nächstes Jahr?
Ja gut, muss man gucken. Ich meine, das hängt ja immer so ein bisschen davon
ab, welche Sau jetzt gerade wieder durchs Dorf getrieben wird.
Und jetzt kann es sehr wohl sein, dass auch noch der Krieg in der Ukraine da eine Rolle spielt.
Kann aber auch natürlich irgendwas
anderes sein. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht so schön zu sehen,
wenn so Länder wie Schweden, die man ja immer gemeinhin im ach so stabilen und
ausgeglichenen und sozial denkenden Skandinavien verortet, so ein bisschen aus der Spur geraten.
Aber da ist halt auch einfach politisch einiges passiert in den letzten zehn
Jahren, die einfach dann dieses innere Stabilisierungsgerüst der Gesellschaft
ein wenig aus den Fugen gebracht hat.
Man muss halt gucken, ob sich das wieder gefixt bekommt. Aber derzeit geht es
da auf jeden Fall nicht so schön ab.
Ja, das stimmt. Wir haben auch noch Feedback, wir haben tatsächlich Herr der
Ringe-Nerds unter den Zuhörerinnen.
Das ist ja mal total überraschend jetzt.
Ja, oder? Hat mich auch total überrascht. Ich hatte fest darauf gezählt,
dass wir nur Star Trek-Fans haben, um jetzt hier einen Krieg in den Kommentaren zu starten.
Star Trek. Du bist ja so ein Star Trek-Nerd, ne?
Ich bin eher, na was heißt nerd, ich bin halt eher Star Trek.
Trekkie. Du bist Trekkie, sag es einfach. Du bist Trekkie. Wie nennt man eigentlich
die Leute, die mehr so Star Wars sind? Die haben eigentlich gar nicht so einen Namen.
Chewbacca. Chewbaccas?
Ja. Okay, ich gebe zu, ich bin ein Chewbacca.
Klingt auch ein bisschen merkwürdig. Aber ich weiß nicht, mir war zum Beispiel
Star Trek immer zu militärisch.
So?
In seinem ganzen Habitus da im Raumschiff immer so, ja Kommandant Pipapo und so.
Und Star Wars ist immer geil, so dreckigere Bällen irgendwie.
Hat mich mehr angesprochen, aber vielleicht ist es auch einfach die straightere
Prinzessin in Geschichte. Das könnte ich auch sagen.
Irgendwas hab ich aber angetan. Oder vielleicht auch der Wortschatz von Chewbacca,
der dich persönlich angesprochen hat.
Also auf jeden Fall Star Wars hatte es leider nicht in allen Filmen gelungen.
Im Mitteltal wurde es ein bisschen schwierig, aber der Humor war schon ganz gut.
So Sachen wie I love you, I know sind schon wirklich echte Klassiker.
Aber kommen wir zu Herr der Ringe, das ist ja auch ein sehr komplexes System,
das zu durchschauen mir nie gelungen ist, weil ich im Vorgespräch festgestellt
habe, dass ich wahrscheinlich immer noch nicht die vollständige Filmmenge konsumiert
habe, weil es mehr ist, als ich dachte.
Wer weiß denn dann schon, dass das ist, also wir sind wahrscheinlich wieder alle außer mir,
aber ich hatte das nicht so auf dem Zeiger, dass es irgendwie von jenem Film
von diesen dreien eine vier Stunden Version gibt, die es natürlich dann auf
Blu-ray gibt, warum auch immer.
Ja, aber früher war das nicht auf Blu-ray. Also als ich die geguckt habe,
war das bestimmt noch auf DVD gefühlt.
Ja, das passt doch da gar nicht drauf.
Ja, es gab mehrere. Die musste man dann irgendwie wechseln.
Ich erinnere mich da noch dran. Das ist ja wie Unix installieren in den 90ern,
wo man mit so einem Diskettenstapel von einem Rechner saß und eine Diskette
nach der anderen einlegen musste.
Das ist so ein bisschen so, wie wenn man früher Hörspieler auf Schallplatte
gehört hat und dann die Schallplatten umdrehen und wechseln musste.
Genau. Okay, also der Herr der Ringe, was habt ihr falsch gemacht?
Snoopy hat uns gerettet.
Snoopy, genau ich lese mal vor. Snoopy hier. Da hat Linus Khaleesi aber ganz
knapp gerettet. Die Palantiri wurden von dem größten aller Elbenschmiede Feanor
geschaffen. Die Elben bzw.
Noldori haben den Numenoran sieben der Steine gegeben.
Sie zeigen in Raum und Zeit in
weit entfernte Szenen und halten über lange Distanzen Kontakt zueinander.
In der Tolkien-Geschichte wurden sie von den Herrschenden benutzt,
um die Reiche zu koordinieren und Gefahren abzuwenden.
Der Stein aus Minas Itil wurde von den Nazgûl bei der Eroberung der Stadt in
Besitz genommen und Sauron übergeben.
Sauron hat einen so starken Willen, dass er den anderen Nutzenden der Palantiri,
Nämlich Denethor Truxess von Gondor in Minas Tirith und Saruman,
Vorsitzender des Weißen Rates in Ortank, eigene Szenen und Gedanken bei der
Benutzung aufzwingen kann.
Das ist in den Filmen auch passiert, so ist Saruman auf die Seite Saurons gewechselt.
Denethor ist durch den Kontakt zu Sauron durch den Palantir wahnsinnig geworden,
soweit zum Hintergrund der sehenden Steine in Tolkiens Fantasy-Universum.
Genau und da muss ich natürlich auch gleich mein Nooblevel auch noch mal irgendwie erhöhen.
Die Bücher habe ich natürlich nie in der Hand gehabt. Also Everything I Know
About Herr der Ringe, I Know From the Movies und dann nicht mal die habe ich vollständig gesehen.
Also ich bin da, keine Ahnung, ich schäme mich auch ein bisschen.
Ich glaube ich hatte mal den Hobbit in der Hand, aber den habe ich nicht zu
Ende gelesen. Ich frage mich warum, ich weiß es nicht.
Und was gibt dir das Herr der Ringe?
Was mir das gibt?
Ja.
Also ich hab, also es ist glaube ich bestimmt zehn Jahre her,
dass ich die Filme das letzte Mal geguckt habe.
Ich hab aber tatsächlich, es gibt doch jetzt eine Serie, ich hab aber,
ich glaube sie heißt The Power of the Rings oder so, ich hab,
oh Gott, bin ich schlecht, wo es um die Vorgeschichte zu dieser, zu Herr der Ringe gibt.
Ich hab angefangen das zu gucken.
Ich glaube Rings of Power.
The Rings of Power, so rum. Genau. Ich habe angefangen das zu gucken in einem
sehr Binge-Modus und dann habe ich irgendwann aufgehört, aber ich weiß nicht warum.
Guck mal hier.
Ja.
The Rings of Power.
Das einzige, was mich immer noch irritiert, ist, dass der Schauspieler, der Dr.
Watson in Sherlock Holmes spielt, den Hobbit spielt.
Das finde ich immer noch komisch.
Den Hobbit in der Film, der Hobbit?
Ja, genau.
It's a crazy world out there. Wir haben das jetzt auf jeden Fall mal klargestellt,
wie das so ist und geben zu, dass wir davon eigentlich keine Ahnung haben.
Ich finde es toll. Also ich meine, es klingt jetzt so, als würde ich das nicht
mögen oder so vielleicht.
Ich finde, ich finde das, ich finde so diese ganze, hast du früher mal,
hast du mal so Rollenspiele gespielt?
Nein.
Nein? Bist du schon mal in der Situation in deinem Leben gewesen,
darüber nachzudenken, ob du Rollenspiele spielen möchtest? Bist du gefragt worden oder so etwas?
Also ich muss mich jetzt outen und danach darf ich bestimmt nie wiederkommen,
aber ich hasse jegliche Form von... Spielen? Spielen, also so Gesellschaftsspiele,
Brettspiele, alles was damit zu tun hat.
Deswegen bin ich auch nie in die Situation gekommen, weil ich glaube,
keiner traut mich das zu fragen und vielleicht finde ich das ganz toll.
Weil du jetzt schon so ganz giftig anschaust, wenn man nur Hase und Igel spielen möchte oder sowas.
Mensch, ärgere dich nicht.
Ja gut, ich meine, Mensch, ärgere dich nicht ist auch wirklich ein bisschen,
das geht gar nicht. Aber Hase und Igel finde ich super.
Ich kenne das gar nicht.
Das war mal Spiel des Jahres, das ist schon eine Weile her. Das ist ein sehr
einfaches Spiel, kann ich dir sehr empfehlen.
Also wenn Gesellschaftsspiel, würde ich sagen, Hase und Igel,
ist ein sehr guter Einstieg, weil da muss man so eine gewisse mathematische
Optimierungskunst an den Tag legen. Insofern ganz interessant.
Und was Rollenspiele betrifft, da muss man halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
Also das Faszinierende ist, das ist ja eigentlich für, also ist ja so ein soziales Spiel für Nuts?
Deren Kernkompetenz gemeinnahm ja nicht das soziale Spiel ist.
Vielleicht ist es deswegen nicht für mich.
Ja, aber es funktioniert, also das kann schon sein, aber trotzdem funktioniert
es ja offensichtlich da.
Und kann man sich natürlich auch die Frage stellen, warum eigentlich.
Und es könnte sein, dass es was mit Würfeln zu tun hat und so,
aber eigentlich glaube ich, die die Power hinter Rollen spielen,
ist dieser Mythos dieser tollkienischen Welt,
der einfach so dieses alternate universe
abenteuer ohne jetzt so richtige superhelden sondern eher so alle alle sind
so ein bisschen zauberhaft jeder hat so eine fähigkeit ja man kann aber auch
so ein ganz komischer gnomen sein
und trotzdem irgendwie seine stärken ausspielen in der komplexen Welt.
Ich glaube, das ist so in der Mischung von allem was dabei.
Und ich habe eine Weile Rollenspiele gespielt und das Lustige ist,
was ich, wozu es geführt hat.
Weil es hat so was ganz anderem geführt, als ich dachte, wir haben es nämlich
eigentlich alles falsch gemacht. Also am Anfang haben wir es gespielt und fanden
es irgendwie toll und so.
Und dann fängst du dann irgendwann an, dass du mit dem Regelwerk nicht zufrieden
bist. Dann fängst du an, deine Regeln anzupassen.
Dann musst du die natürlich dann auch irgendwann aufschreiben.
Und in meinem Fall war das halt so in 80er Jahren.
Und dann führte das dazu, dass ich irgendwie Textverarbeitung,
Software benutzt habe. Davon gab es früher gar nicht so viel.
Und auf jeden Fall haben wir dann aber dieses ganze Regelwerk geschrieben.
Aber das Das Schreiben dieses Regelwerks hat dann dazu geführt,
dass ich Deutsch richtig gelernt habe.
Und da bin ich dann so ein... Naja, ich meine, man lernt ja so die Sprache in der Schule.
Ja.
Aber es ist ja so ein bisschen wie mit dem Programmieren. Erst wenn du wirklich
selber was machst damit, fängst du an, das so richtig zu lernen.
Weil dann ist es irgendwie auf einmal wichtig.
Also mir ging es auf jeden Fall so. Also ich habe auf jeden Fall so deutsche
Grammatik und Rechtschreibung und so weiter.
Habe ich einfach durch das Schreiben von Rollenspielregelwerken ganz gut gelernt.
Aber es war alles so anstrengend und die Regeln waren am Ende so komplex,
dass keiner mehr spielen wollte. Und dann hab ich das irgendwie auch nicht weitergeführt.
Aber Deutsch kam dabei auch.
Also so wie sich so EU-Politik anfühlt, so stell ich mir das irgendwie vor.
Jetzt stellt sich die Frage, sitzen die da im Parlament mit W20-Würfeln?
Jetzt wissen wir endlich, wie der Trilogen funktioniert.
Ich habe ja ein plus fünf auf Überwachungsgesetze. Ja, warum das denn ja?
Ich bin bei der CDU.
Da hat auch jeder Gnomen seine zauberhaften Fähigkeiten entfalten.
Fischereigesetze zum Beispiel.
Was wir bei Tolkien über die Politik gelernt haben.
Aber vielleicht wäre das ja, also eigentlich ist das ja voll die gute Idee,
so könnte man vielleicht die EU-Politik ein bisschen nahbarer machen.
Also ich wäre total dazu bereit, das als Rollenspiel zu kreieren.
Also wenn es Interessierte gibt, ich wäre dabei.
Und das, obwohl du Spiele nicht magst, das ist interessant.
Ja, aber ich mag ja Jugendpolitik.
Das ist ja auch weird irgendwie.
Es wäre eine akzeptable, es gibt auch so ein Spiel, doch ein Spiel,
es gibt auch ein ein dieses Einbürgerungstestspiel.
Gibt es? Das ist sehr lustig. Ja, das ist dann, das ist so ein bisschen wie
Trival Pursuit, aber mit Einbürgerungstests Fragen.
Und der, der halt am Ende ausreichend Fragen beantwortet hat und den Einbürgerungstest
bestehen würde, hat dann gewonnen.
Aha, okay. Das gibt's wirklich also so als Spiel?
Ja. Ja, ich hab's doch schon gewonnen. Ist das ernst gemeint oder ist das so?
Ja, das gibt es wirklich.
Also ich meine, ist das sozusagen Teil, also ist das sozusagen ums zu lernen
oder ist das um sich darüber lustig zu machen?
Ich glaube, es ist eher dazu da, um sich über die Deutschen lustig zu machen,
die selber den Einmöbungstest nicht bestehen würden.
Ja, aber im Prinzip kann man es darüber aber auch lernen.
Bestimmt.
Ja. Geil. Sollen wir mal spielen?
Aber erstmal müssen wir die Sendung fertig machen. Kommen wir zu den Nachrichten,
zu den eigentlichen Nachrichten.
Es gibt eine neue Chefin beim BSI. Also gibt es noch nicht, sondern wird es erst geben. Am 1.
Juli 2023 soll quasi die Nachfolgerin von Arne Schönbrom beim BSI anfangen und
die Wahl fiel auf Claudia Plattner,
eine Mathematikerin und bisher Generaldirektorin für Informationssysteme bei
der Europäischen Zentralbank und mir vollständig unbekannt bisher. Wie ging es dir?
Ja, mir auch. Ich habe dann auch gelernt, dass sie vorher zuständig war für
die IT der Deutschen Bahn oder die Modernisierung der IT.
Aber was ich mich gefragt habe in diesem Zuge, wie viele BSI-Chefinnen gab es
eigentlich schon? Weißt du das?
Ich würde mal auf keiner tippen.
Nein, also, ja, Chefs oder Chefinnen.
Ach so, wie viele?
Sie ist die erste Frau, das weiß ich. Ach so, ja, okay. vieles insgesamt gab,
weil ich habe sehr überrascht festgestellt.
Ich würde mal tippen, wenige, drei, vier, fünf?
Ich war nie dann alle so lange im Amt.
BSE gibt es seit 30 Jahren, ne? Da müssen eigentlich mehr sein, ne?
Ich weiß nicht, sag mal. Hätte ich jetzt auch, ich weiß es nicht.
Achso, du weißt es nicht? Ich dachte, nee.
Ich konnte es auch nicht so auf die Schnelle rausfinden, deswegen dachte ich,
du weißt ja alles, wie du vorhin richtig festgestellt hast.
Naja, also.
Aber was sehr schön ist, dass in dieser 30 Jahre Pressemitteilung drinsteht,
Prävention, Detektion und Reaktion,
fand ich irgendwie eine sehr schöne Sammlung von Wörtern zum BSI.
Aber ja, ich hoffe einfach, dass die Frau Plattner es besser macht.
Und ich glaube, Netzpolitik hat unter dem schönen Titel Wünsche an die neue
BSI-Chefin ein paar Echoes dazu gesammelt.
Und mal gucken, ob die gute Frau es schafft, unabhängig vom BMI zu werden.
Das wäre eigentlich so wirklich eine wirklich interessante Frage.
Aber ansonsten hat sie, glaube ich, auch echt gut zu tun.
Wir werden sehen.
Wir werden sehen. Also du bist aber da zuversichtlich.
Ja, ich habe so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, weißt du, so Deutsche Bahn,
Zentralbank, das sind jetzt auch nicht so die einfachsten Läden,
um sich mit der IT zu beschäftigen.
Man kann jetzt nicht darüber streiten, wie gut es da mit der ET läuft,
aber das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema.
Aber ich habe schon das Gefühl, dass Claudia Plattner schon ein bisschen mehr
Erfahrung und Einsicht mitbringt.
Und ich hoffe, dass sie da einfach mal ein bisschen Pragmatisches durchgreift
und keine komischen Dinger dreht.
Und sie hat ja auch wirklich gut zu tun, diese Überwachungs- und Cyber-Fantasien,
die das BMI hat, oder diese Visionen wieder zurückzudrehen.
Also die kommt jetzt auch in ihre eigene, um dieses Tolkienmuster,
in ihr eigenes Rollenspiel. Mal gucken, welche Würfel da fallen.
Ja, genau, mit welchen Fähigkeiten sie da aufläuft. Also ich habe immer nicht
so viele Hoffnungen bei solchen Instituten, die sich dann am Ende ja doch so
der Leitpolitik fügen müssen, aber ja, warten wir das mal ab.
Ich habe mich gefragt, ob es irgendwas mit Hustle Plattner und diesem ganzen
Kosmos zu tun hat und ich habe so den Eindruck, hat es nicht.
Ich habe da zumindest keinen Zusammenhang gesehen, weil ich mich gefragt habe,
ob wir jetzt sozusagen da so neue Dynastien auf einmal in unsere IT bezogene
Politik bekommen, aber dem scheint nicht so zu sein.
Außerdem ist Hasno Plattner ja noch dabei, Potsdam wieder alt-neu zu modernisieren.
Okay, naja, das hat er damit ausgerechnet beschäftigt. Immerhin gründet er keine Fußballvereine.
Sowas gibt es denn Neues bei der Chat-Kontrolle?
Ja, es ist wirklich tatsächlich mal richtig viel passiert und auch so ein paar
gute Sachen und ein paar sehr kuriose Sachen.
Apropos Fußballverein, hast du es gesehen, dass die Fans von Hertha BSC beim
letzten Spiel gegen die Tad Kontrolle demonstriert haben?
Mir ist tatsächlich so ein Screenshot irgendwo untergekommen,
aber ich habe es nicht im bewegten Bild gesehen, ja. Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Okay, ich dachte vielleicht hast du es im bewegten Bild gesehen.
Nee.
Sind ich auch Fußballfan?
Jaja, aber nicht von Hertha BSC, aber das fand ich trotzdem ganz gut.
Aber ich habe nur so ein Bild davon gesehen und nicht genau den Hintergrund.
Also der Hintergrund ist klar. Also auch in den Fußballszenen ist natürlich
das Überwachungsthema schon lange ein großes Ding.
Also weil das ja auch so ein Aspekt, der oft übersehen wird.
Wir haben so bestimmte Narrative in der Gesellschaft, wo so das Böse wohnt.
Und das muss ja nicht unbedingt immer so ein bisschen was mit der Realität zu
tun haben. Aber so diese Assoziation Fußballfans, Hooliganismus,
Bedrohung der Gesellschaft, die ist ja sehr verbreitet.
Und es gibt ja da in dem Feld schon seit längerem halt entsprechende Karteien bei der Polizei,
wo dann eben einzelne Fußballfans einfach reingepackt werden,
weil sie bei irgendwelchen Standardkontrollen erfasst werden.
So ja, zeig mal hier Personalausweis, dann sind die da irgendwie drin.
Und das führt dann irgendwann, obwohl denen nie irgendwas vorgeworfen wurde,
führt das dann mal dazu, dass sie so Hausverbot erteilt bekommen oder irgendwo
raus sortiert werden oder irgendwo nicht hinfliegen dürfen und so eine Geschichten.
Und dementsprechend ist so die Sensibilität in dem Fußball-Ultra-Bereich für
Überwachungsmaßnahmen und Polizeimaßnahmen, die nur so begrenzt von Gesetzen gedeckt sind bzw.
Gesetzesverschärfungen, die genau hier die Fähigkeiten der Polizei weiter erweitern,
relativ hoch. Das muss man schon sagen.
Ja, genau. Also die Fahnhilfe ist tatsächlich auch ganz vorne dabei bei unserem
Deutschen Bündnis für die Tet-Controller. Die engagieren sich auch relativ viel
im Bereich biometrische Massenüberwachung genau aus diesen Gründen.
Und das kriegt man, finde ich, immer alles gar nicht so mit.
Aber ich wollte eigentlich gute Sachen erzählen. Oh ja.
Also tatsächlich ist es so, es wurden mal wieder Protokolle aus der Strafverfolgungs-
Gruppe im Rat, also auf EU-Ebene geleakt.
Und Deutschland hat sich, obwohl wir noch keine neue Position haben,
auf die wir immer noch sehr gespannt warten, tatsächlich mal ein bisschen besser
positioniert und auch mal gesagt, dass sie verschlüsselte Kommunikation dann
doch ganz gerne schützen wollen würden.
Also Verbesserungen sind durchaus zu erkennen.
Also es bleibt abzuwarten, was jetzt in der Position steht und man muss auch
sehr realistisch sagen,
auch wenn es theoretisch möglich ist, so ein Gesetz im Rat zu kippen,
müsste Deutschland, glaube ich, schon sehr viel Werbung machen und sich sehr
krass positionieren, damit wir es schaffen, das im Rat zu kippen.
Also nur so am Rande. Aber es ist noch was passiert. Erinnerst du dich noch an Ilver Johanns, Tim?
Ilva Johansson, ich bin mir nicht sicher, wer war das? Die EU Kommissarin war das.
Genau, das ist die EU Kommissarin, der wir die Chatkontrolle zu verdanken haben.
Die war's.
Und die wird jetzt natürlich langsam ein bisschen nervös, weil irgendwie so
Druck steigt und alle sind nicht so wirklich begeistert von ihrem Proposal.
Und dann hat sie sich halt mal überlegt, das wäre vielleicht ja ganz gut,
mal die Leute in Berlin zu besuchen, die sie so krass kritisieren.
Und deswegen war sie tatsächlich letzte Woche in Berlin und hat sich mit Nancy
Feser und Marco Buschmann getroffen.
Es gab tatsächlich danach keine Pressekonferenz. Man weiß nicht so genau,
was da nachgelaufen ist.
Aber Marco Buschmann hat danach getwittert.
Ich krieg nicht mehr alles zusammen. Deshalb lehnen wir generelle Überwachungsmaßnahmen,
private Konfeparisspendenzen gerade auch im digitalen Raum ab.
Also ich glaube, das Gespräch ist für sie nicht ganz so gut verlaufen,
wie sie sich das vorgestellt hatte.
Also Marco Buschmann, unser aktueller Justizminister, muss man vielleicht auch
auch noch mal dazu sagen. Ich glaube viele Leute haben die ganzen Namen nicht immer so parat.
Das ist gut.
Genau. Ja, das ist gut. Im Rahmen dessen hat sie auch ein Spiegelinterview gegeben.
Und ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, da haben wir noch nie drüber in der Sendung
gesprochen, aber sie hat immer sehr kuriose Argumente, die sie so am Start hat.
Also sie sagt zum Beispiel, naja, Kleinzeit-Scanning ist eigentlich genau das
Gleiche wie Autokorrektur.
Oh, gewagte These.
Und in dem Interview hat sie dann natürlich auch gesagt, dass es Erkennungstechnologien
gibt, die so eingesetzt werden können, dass die Verschlüsselung erhalten bleibt.
Lieblingszitat, ich glaube, das wird ihr auch sehr gefallen.
Es ist viermal so, als würde man einen Polizeihund Pakete beschnuppern lassen,
ob sich darin Kokain verbirgt.
Also die Polizei geht jetzt nicht nur im Internet auf Streife,
wir brauchen auch noch Hunde.
Im Telefon, ja.
Genau. Soweit, so absurd.
Sie hat auch den Big Brother Award diese Woche bekommen in den Niederlanden
und hat ihn tatsächlich auch entgegen genommen.
Es war außerdem auch noch ihr Geburtstag, also sehr kurioses Situation und sie
hat all diese seltsamen Argumente dann auch noch mal in ihrer Rede gemacht.
Das erst mal zu Eva Johansson und das ist übrigens das erste Mal,
dass sie mit der Zivilgesellschaft gesprochen hat über dieses Proposal,
also jedenfalls mit der Zivilgesellschaft, die sich mit Netzpolitik beschäftigt.
Davor hat sie das immer abgelehnt.
Ja, genau. So viel zu dieser Verrittenheit.
Das heißt, sie ist besser als ich sozusagen.
Weiß ich nicht. Also, wenn man sich die Rede anhört, es ist ein Rebuttal.
Und sie verteilt darin eigentlich nur ihr Proposal.
Und du kannst eigentlich ein Trinkspiel daraus machen, weil ihr Lieblingssatz
ist, glaube ich, My Proposal.
Und es ist wirklich so, my proposal will save the world.
Ja, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Schwierig. Aber um nochmal nach dieser traurigen Sache
zur Tätkontrolle zu einer besseren, einem guten Ereignis zu kommen,
es wurden noch ein paar mehr Sachen geleakt diese Woche.
Und zwar wurde der Report eines der Ausschüsse, dem IMKO Ausschuss, geleakt.
Was ist das für ein Ausschuss?
Das ist der Ausschuss für den internen Markt.
Also im Europäischen Parlament.
Genau. Vielleicht nochmal um so ein Stepback zu machen.
Im EU-Gesetzgebungsprozess ist es so, dass ein Gesetz vorgestellt wird und dann
wird es an Ausschüsse gegeben, die dann einen Report schreiben.
Das ist aber eigentlich nur ein Dokument, was Änderungsanträge zu diesem Gesetz
enthält und die werden dann abgestimmt.
Und derzeit ist es so, dass der Liebeausschuss federführend ist.
Das ist der Ausschuss für Menschenrechte und Justiz.
Der IMKO-Ausschuss wird jetzt aber wahrscheinlich, so wie es aussieht, Kompetenzen bekommen.
Basierend auf diesen Kompetenzen, die sie wahrscheinlich bekommen,
das wird noch entschieden.
Einen ersten Entwurf ihres Reports gemacht und der sieht sehr, sehr gut aus.
Also sie haben in diesem Report vorgesehen,
dass nur nach bekannten Material gesucht werden darf und das Suchen nach Grooming
und unbekannten Material schließen sie vollständig aus.
Dann verpflichten sie die Anbieterinnen genauso wie die EU bei der Erstellung
von Maßnahmen die Auswirkungen sehr genau zu überprüfen und zu gucken,
ob sie mit den Menschenrechten vereinbar sind.
Sie wollen Schwerpunkt auf den Schutz von Technologien setzen,
die vertrauliche und verschlüsselte Kommunikation gewährleisten.
Ich weiß nicht, erinnerst du dich noch an das EU-Center in dieser Chatkontrollengesetzgebung?
Ne, ehrlich gesagt nicht. EU-Center für?
Genau, also in diesem Gesetz steht drin, dass es einen EU-Center geben soll,
was halt sozusagen das bekannte Material,
ich sag mal, also eine Datenbank an bekannten Material vorhält,
aber auch Technologie zur Verfügung stellt, mit dem man Material finden kann
und das Problem bei diesem EU-Center.
Also so analog, wie das die Amerikaner machen.
Genau, analog zum NICMAC, so heißt es in Amerika. Aber das Problem dabei war,
dass das halt bei Europol angegliedert werden sollte.
Das heißt, das wollen sie auch ausschließen, diese Angliederung.
Und sie streichen tatsächlich auch Altersverifikationen komplett.
Und sie wollen auch Mechanismen implementieren, die Benutzer auch ausreichend
informieren, da jetzt eigentlich passiert. Also es sieht alles sehr,
sehr gut aus, was die da gemacht haben.
Und das einzige, wo sie nicht ran konnten, weil das erinnerst du dich vielleicht
auch noch, ist dieses ganze Thema Netzsperren.
Das liegt leider halt nicht in der Kompetenzbereich, deswegen konnten sie es
halt auch nicht streichen.
Aber es sieht sehr, sehr gut aus und ich hoffe, hoffe wirklich,
dass die anderen Ausschüsse sich daran ein Vorbild nehmen. Die haben jetzt hier
sehr stark vorgelegt und Mandat.
Den schlimmen Kram rausbekommt. Also alles.
Das ist ja echt interessant. Der Ausschuss, wenn ich das richtig verstanden
habe, der Ausschuss für Binnenmarkt- und Verbraucherschutz hat jetzt sozusagen
sein Statement abgegeben.
Und reinweise jetzt quasi... Abmilderungen, sag ich mal, gegenüber den bisherigen
Proposals vorgestellt, die so bisher vom Ausschuss für bürgerliche Freiheiten so nicht kamen.
Also es ist ja nur sozusagen ein erster Entwurf, das heißt es ist noch nicht offiziell.
Aber genau, von dem Liebeausschuss, also von dem für bürgerliche Freiheit kam
halt noch gar nichts, die sind noch sozusagen am diskutieren.
Man muss dazu aber auch sagen, der Berichterstatter vom IMKO,
also von dem internen Marktausschuss, im Binnenmarktausschuss
ist halt von von s&d also
spd sozusagen während der
Berichterstatter von liebe bei der epp also zu deutsch evp also den konservativen
ist ist halt nicht so verwunderlich dass die jetzt da nicht vorstürmen unbedingt
oder da ein bisschen zögerlicher sind.
All right.
Übrigens muss ich dich korrigieren. Das war nicht halt der BSC.
Das Plakat war Hansa Rostock.
Das ist ein schwerer Fehler.
Jetzt weiß ich auch warum ich die Information so verwirrt hat in dem Moment
so vor der eigenen Haustür, das hätte ich glaube ich noch mal anders abgespeichert,
aber jetzt erinnere ich mich auch wieder.
Verdammt.
Das waren die Fans von Hansa Rostock, aber ich glaube das betrifft wirklich
alle Fanszenen und so. Nur interessant, dass die auf die Idee gekommen sind.
Genau, aber das war irgendwie soweit das Ding mit der Chatkontrolle.
Und es bleibt weiter spannend. Mal gucken, wann die Regierung mit ihrer Positionierung um die Ecke kommt.
Gut, blicken wir sowohl in die Ukraine als auch in die USA.
Schlechte Nachrichten mit Elon Musk haben wir heute wieder einige dabei.
Das ist so eins, also Starlink, das Internetprovider Subprojekt von SpaceX,
der Raketenfirma von Maske und Co.
Ist ja eigentlich eine tolle Sache, weil das funktioniert wenigstens und das
gibt es auch schon so und das finde ich bemerkenswert. Ich weiß nicht,
ob du schon mal in den Segen von Starlink Internetversorgung gekommen bist.
Dank dir ja.
Dank mir. Ach so. Ja, echt hast du daran schon Teil gehabt. Na,
sehr gut. Ja, ich habe so eine Schüssel genau.
Und da ich ja oft in Deutschland unterwegs bin, ist es so gerade im Sommer ganz
hilfreich, so eine Schüssel dabei zu haben, weil dann gibt es halt auch Netz. Ja, das ist geil.
Also das muss ich auch sagen. So als Produkt ist es wirklich toll. Also es ist wirklich so.
Kaufst es, stellst es irgendwie auf den Rasen, machst Strom dran und dann macht
es so bing und dann gibt es irgendwie Netz. Die funktioniert einfach.
Das klang jetzt so wie früher. Das ist so das neue Verbindungsgeräusch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die App tatsächlich irgendein Geräusch macht.
Ich habe immer die Töne bei meinen Apps ausgeschaltet.
Von daher keine Ahnung. Aber vom Ablauf her läuft es halt genauso.
Es konfiguriert sich selber, guckst dich den Himmel an, steht ein,
zwei Minuten rum und du sagst, ach ja, Übrigens jetzt gibt es Netz und dann
funktioniert das irgendwie auch.
Genauso das Gegenteil zu den sonstigen Internet-Erfahrungen in Deutschland.
Naja und in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren wurde es auch massiv ausgebaut.
Also ist die Verfügbarkeit in immer mehr Ländern sichergestellt und jüngst gab
es dann auch, glaube ich, ein paar polare Satelliten, die das jetzt sozusagen
auch weit in den Norden verlängern.
Bandbreite ist besser geworden, Software ist besser geworden etc.
Pp. Und natürlich spielt auch Starlink in der Ukraine eine große Rolle und es
ist überhaupt gar keine überhaupt gar kein Geheimnis,
dass dort seit der Invasion Russlands, das ukrainische Militär Starlink,
kräftig zum Einsatz bringt.
Nicht nur weil halt die Internetinfrastruktur sowie jede Infrastruktur durch
die Russen akut gefährdet, bedroht und zerstört wird, das natürlich auch die
Internetinfrastruktur betrifft.
Aber natürlich ist es auch an der Front ein hilfreiches Tool.
Die Ukraine setzt Software ein, die so quasi ihre ganzen militärischen Aktivitäten
an der Front so koordiniert sowie ja, sowieso Miettaxis.
Das heißt, Ziele werden oder Lieferdienste, also Ziele werden ausgemacht.
Es gibt halt irgendeine Intelligence, wo ein Angriff stattfindet,
wo es eine Truppkonzentration gibt, wo irgendwelches Militärgerät rumsteht, was auch immer.
Und in dem Moment, wo halt die Koordinaten davon bekannt sind,
können die halt schnell an ein System gemeldet werden, an dem dann eben auch
verschiedenste Einsatztruppen auch registriert sind und dann werden die die
halt mehr oder weniger automatisch dispatcht. Das ist wirklich krass.
Und das führt eben dazu, dass die Ukraine sich trotz der Zahlenüberlegenheit
und der Militärüberlegenheit der russischen Militärmaschine noch vergleichsweise
gut zur Wehr setzen kann. Jetzt stört das allerdings Starlink.
Das Unternehmen hat sich jetzt irgendwie geäußert und meint so,
ja, wissen Sie, Starlink sei ja nie als Waffe gedacht gewesen.
So, und da hätten Sie ja jetzt überhaupt nicht daran gedacht,
dass es eine militärische Nutzung hätte geben können.
Ja, ich hätte das gedacht, dass man das auch für Militärsachen nutzt.
Das kommt jetzt total überraschend. Das war in meinem Thread-Model überhaupt nicht enthalten.
Ja, echte totale Breaking News. Das ist natürlich totaler Bullshit,
weil das wissen sie von Anfang an.
Sie sind ja auch irgendwie von den Russen permanent gehackt worden und es gab
dann halt die verschiedensten Versuche der Russen, Starlink in irgendeiner Form
in der Kommunikation außer Gefecht zu sitzen. Das ist ihnen nicht gelungen.
Und natürlich wissen die das. Aber jetzt kommen sie halt irgendwie mit so,
ja und überhaupt und versuchen halt die offensive Nutzung zu verhindern.
Inwiefern ihnen das jetzt gelingt oder wie krass sie da jetzt wirklich versuchen
Infrastruktur abzuschalten, ist noch nicht klar. Es gab einen ähnlichen Vorfall
schon, dass sie irgendwie die Nutzung auf der Krim irgendwie nicht ermöglichen wollen.
Das ist jetzt noch nicht so ganz das akute Thema, aber all diese ganzen Maßnahmen
sind natürlich ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Das öffnet jetzt mehrere Perspektiven. Also erstmal stellt sich natürlich die
Frage, ist Elon Musk irgendwie so ein Russentool?
Was reitet die jetzt da eigentlich gerade den Ukrainern noch das Leben schwer
zu machen, obwohl ihre Technologie eigentlich wunderbar geeignet ist,
diesen Angriffskrieg in irgendeiner Form handeln zu können?
Aber was natürlich jetzt auch hier mit verbunden ist,
ist inwiefern ist jetzt eine Internet, satellitengestützte Internetinfrastruktur in der Zukunft eine,
ja, so eine Infrastruktur, die jeder politische Blog mit eigenen Sicherheitsinteressen
vielleicht benötigt, der es sich leisten kann.
Und die EU hat sich gedacht, okay, wir müssen auch ein Starlink bauen.
Ganz klar. Ja, ja.
Also das ist ja, das ist ja, ich weiß ja nicht, inwiefern du das so begleitest,
aber es gibt ja schon seit längerem eine interessante Konstellation in der ganzen
europäischen Raumfahrt.
Lange lange Zeit war das ja primär so ein Wissenschafts- und Wirtschaftsding.
Also die ESA als paneuropäische...
Also die ESA? Bitte?
Wo besteht ESA?
Space Agency, das ist so quasi das Equivalenz zu NASA.
Die jeder kennt, aber die ESA kennt irgendwie nicht jeder,
aber die Europäische Raumfahrtagentur mit dem Sitz der Zentrale in Paris ist
halt über Europa hin überall vertreten.
Die müssen auch nicht andauernd umziehen. Haben sie Glück gehabt.
Die müssen nicht umziehen. Die ESA hat mehrere sehr große Niederlassungen.
Eine sehr große bei Rom, in Italien, in Spanien, in Paris, eben die Zentrale
des Raumfahrtkontrollzentrums in Darmstadt.
Das sind so die großen, und das S-RIN, also das Technikzentrum in Holland,
das sind so die großen Niederlassungen. Und dann gibt es natürlich quer über
Europa verteilt überall noch weitere Aktivitäten.
Und das ist ja ein Erfolgsmodell eigentlich, kann man sagen.
Also die ESA hat in den 70er Jahren noch klein angefangen und war eigentlich
noch gar nichts und hat dann mit dem Ariane-Raketenprogramm es eigentlich geschafft
zu so einem Global Player zu werden,
weil es einfach die lange, lange Zeit die zuverlässigste Launcherkapazität war
so im ganzen Raketenbereich.
Die Amerikaner hatten so ihre Probleme, die Russen auch.
Ariane-Raketen haben sehr gut funktioniert und so hat sich das halt ganz gut
etabliert und das ist insofern ein Segen. jetzt gibt es seit ein paar Jahren
auch die EU als Auftraggeber.
Die ESA ist nicht die EU. Also die ESA ist halt eine im Wesentlichen als europäische
Wirtschaftsinitiative gedachte Struktur.
Da wird halt Geld reingetan, da sollen neue Missionen entwickelt werden.
Neue Missionen entwickeln heißt halt immer neue Technologie entwickeln,
weil jede Raumfahrtmission ist halt neu.
Alles was neu ins All geschickt wird, hat es so vorher noch nie gegeben und
deswegen ist das halt einfach so ein Motor, so ein Innovationsmotor für Technologieentwicklung
auf allen Ebenen. Das funktioniert ja so wunderbar.
Jetzt gibt es von der EU aber auch finanzierte Projekte, wo also wirklich konkret
die EU ist und das ist zum Beispiel das Galileo Navigationssystem.
Also so wie GPS und GLONASS in Russland gibt es halt auch ein europäisches Navigationssystem.
Wir sagen natürlich, so wie wir immer alle NASA kennen, kennen wir alle irgendwie
GPS, weil das war als erstes da und das benutzen irgendwie alle.
Wobei man heute schon gar nicht mehr genau sagen kann, welches der Systeme denn
jetzt ein Telefon gerade wirklich nutzt.
Also ob da nicht schon auch die die Galileo-Fähigkeit genutzt wird oder die
GLONASS-Fähigkeit genutzt wird, wenn ein GPS in irgendeiner Form gerade mal nicht verfügbar ist.
Und das ist halt von der EU beauftragt. Das sind also sozusagen konkrete EU-gebundene
Projekte, genauso wie das Copernicus-System, was halt auch so ein Weltbeobachtungssystem ist.
Nicht ein Überwachungssystem, sondern eben sowohl für Umweltbeobachtung auf
der einen Seite, aber eben auch so Katastrophenbeobachtung.
Also was weiß ich, wenn es halt große Flüchtlingsbewegungen gibt.
Du willst ja Daten haben, willst ja wirklich auch wissen,
ah okay, hier sind Tausende, Zehntausende oder Hunderttausende Leute vielleicht gerade auf der Flucht,
ja oder Hungersnöte, Regenkatastrophen, Erdbeben,
jetzt gerade die Situation in der Türkei, da kannst du davon ausgehen,
dass diese ganzen Copernicus-Satelliten halt hochgradig wichtige Informationen
liefern, weil die die das einfach extrem gut beobachten können.
Und es hat nicht nur so ein, zwei Satelliten gibt, sondern eine ganze Armada
aus spezialisiertem Beobachtungssystem.
Und diese ganze Frage nach...
Beobachten die da dann unterschiedliche, also unterschiedliche Sachen oder alles,
dass alle das gleich, also die unterschiedlichen Funktionalitäten?
Sehr unterschiedlich. Also es gibt da so dreidimensionale Radarsachen,
die das halt wirklich so im Zentimeterbereich machen. Es gibt welche,
die sind eben so auf Vegetation ausgelegt. welche, die sind auf die Beobachtung
von Wasser, Temperatur, Strömung ausgelegt.
Also das Copernicus-System ist so eine bunte Tüte aus allen möglichen Beobachtungstechniken,
wie man die Erde beobachten kann.
Und das ist auch sehr interessant, weil dort alle Daten als Open Data anfallen.
Also das ist sozusagen alles öffentlich verfügbare Information.
Man kann sich auf diese Daten einfach stürzen. Da gibt es mehr Daten als ausgewertet werden.
Es gibt bloß zusätzlich eben auch noch ein paar spezialisierte Zentren,
die eben konkrete Auswertungen machen.
Also sowohl natürlich die Wissenschaft, aber eben zum Beispiel auch so eine
Katastrophen-Meldezentren etc.
Also wenn wirklich sowas ist
jetzt wie dieses Erdbebengebiet in der also des Erdbeben in der Türkei,
dann kannst du davon ausgehen, dass da sofort Alarm ist und dann innerhalb weniger
Stunden werden dann eben diese Daten dort ausgewertet.
Und dann wissen die ganz genau, wie viele Zentimeter sich da die Erde verschoben
hat, welche Gebiete jetzt konkret davon betroffen sind, wo es Feuer gibt und
so weiter. Also das sind alles solche Sachen, die da rauskommen.
Aber warum ich das jetzt erwähne, ist, dass einfach die EU hier dahinter steht,
dass die das sozusagen als kritische Infrastruktur der Europäischen Union ansieht,
entsprechend finanziert und betreibt.
Wie eben auch das Navigationssystem, weil wenn man ein eigenes Navigationssystem
hat, dann kann einem das nicht abgeschaltet werden.
Und jetzt stellt man sich mal vor, Europa hätte so etwas wie Starlink jetzt
auch im Fall des Überfalls der Ukraine.
Haben wir aber nicht. Jetzt wollen sie sowas bauen. Es gibt da auch ein entsprechendes
Projekt, das heißt irgendwie Iris Hoch, nein nicht Iris, Iris Hoch 2.
Und ein komischer Name allein schon, wurde von dem Thierry Breton.
Breton, das ist auch der Mensch, der Netzneutralität blöd findet.
Ja genau, also der EU-Kommissar für Binnenmarkt und Dienstleistungen,
der hat das irgendwie groß verkündet, dass das jetzt irgendwie kommen soll.
Und jetzt tun sie irgendwie so, als ob Europa demnächst ein eigenes Darlehenkart.
Ja, vor allen Dingen sagen die, dass sie das bis 2024 operational bekommen wollen.
Das finde ich ganz schön ambitioniert.
Also, First Services sollen operational sein 2024 und irgendwie das komplette
System soll 2027 stehen.
Ich kann da auf jeden Fall eins zu sagen, das wird auf gar keinen Fall passieren.
Was ist denn wahrscheinlicher, Tim, dass wir Breitbandausbau in Deutschland
also kriegen so richtig oder dass wir ein europäisches Starlink bekommen?
Ich meine, das würde ja vielleicht den Breitbandausbau auch lösen.
Also ich glaube, dass jedes Weltereignis in der Lage ist, den Breitbandausbau
in Deutschland zu überholen.
Da habe ich, wie ich schon mehrfach betont habe, keine Hoffnung.
Keine. Das Ding ist durch. Deutschland wird es nicht hinkriegen.
Faxgerät forever. Aber das hier ist auch...
Die haben sie doch jetzt abgeschaltet.
Jaja, von wegen. Die haben überall geheimen Räume, wo die weiter betrieben werden.
So Suchtstation, weißt du, wo dann die Beamten hingehen können?
Ich hab da Fotos gesehen im Internet.
Ne, also es gibt dann verschiedene Probleme damit. Also erst mal bis 2024 kriegen
die überhaupt gar nichts auf die Kette, weil diese Technologie existiert in
dem Sinne noch überhaupt nicht.
Du müsstest eine Produktionsstraße haben, wo, also wenn man sich mal Starlink
nochmal genauer anschaut, was das ist.
Das ist eine Konstellation mit Tausenden von Satelliten, die quasi im industriellen
Maßstab gefertigt werden.
So eine Produktionsstraße existiert in Europa überhaupt nicht.
Und auch diese Satelliten existieren so in der Form noch überhaupt nicht.
Und das scheint ja auch gar nicht das Ziel zu sein. Das Ziel ist hier im Prinzip
so etwas Ähnliches zu bauen,
aber in sehr viel geringerer Kapazität, was sicherlich nicht in der Lage ist,
uns irgendwie auf dem Campingplatz Internet anzubieten, sondern was quasi für,
das deute ich jetzt mal so, militärkritische Grenz-Einheiten,
Frontex, so etwas in der Kategorie so etwas bereitstellen könnte.
Ja, das ist durchaus vorstellbar.
Aber allein die Kapazität, das ins All zu bekommen,
so eine Konstellation, Abgesehen davon, dass du natürlich jetzt hier nicht nur
die Satelliten produzieren musst, sondern das muss dann irgendwie auch noch
alles funktionieren, geplant werden und das muss dann vor allem auch noch alles gelauncht werden.
Dazu brauchst du also auch eine entsprechende Launch Kapazität.
Und das ist halt derzeit ein echtes Problem, weil einfach Europa leider das
Arianesystem ziemlich heruntergewirtschaftet hat in den letzten zehn Jahren.
Also es war mal das zuverlässigste System oder der zuverlässigste Startplatz überhaupt auf der Welt.
Mittlerweile ist der Pokal wieder in den USA und zwar bei SpaceX gelandet,
die alle zwei Wochen irgendwie eine Rakete hochschicken.
Alle zwei Wochen, da träumen die davon in Kourou. Die sind froh,
wenn sie irgendwie jetzt gerade mal alle drei Monate irgendwie eine Rakete hochbekommen.
Und jetzt ist ihnen zuletzt tatsächlich mal eine abgestürzene Vega-Rakete.
Das gab es so vorher auch noch nicht. Und dazu kommt noch, dass der dritte Startplatz
in Kourou war halt von den Russen bedient worden mit einer für den Startplatz
angepassten Sojus-Rakete.
Und das liegt natürlich jetzt auch alles komplett brach. Also das ist sozusagen,
es gibt einfach überhaupt gar nicht diese Launcher-Kapazität.
Am Ende müssten die Amerikaner die europäischen Satelliten hochschicken.
Naja, also das wird man dann alles nochmal sehen, aber das ist bisher auf jeden Fall nochmal dünner.
Allerdings, die Debatte, die halt im Raum steht, ist, so ist Internet eigentlich
eine kritische Infrastruktur? Und was sagen wir dazu?
Ja schon, kann man so sagen.
Aber wir leben schon so lange mit schlechtem Internet, dass wir da relativ gut
drauf vorbereitet sind.
Ja, aber ich meine, es ist auch alles noch gar nicht so lange her,
dass überhaupt dieses Land und Europa auch so im Besonderen überhaupt erst angefangen
hat zu verstehen, dass Internet überhaupt wichtig ist.
Also wie lange ist das so abgetan worden als so, ja, das ist ja alles ein Neuland
und da muss man ja mal gucken und braucht man denn das eigentlich auch wirklich?
Wir haben da noch unser T-Lex.
Es wurde immer als Spielerei gesehen, und dann haben sie sich gewundert,
dass man da nicht so viel Geld verdienen kann. Und jetzt verstehen sie langsam,
dass daraus eine kritische Infrastruktur
und vor allem so ein kritischer Technologievorsprung auch entsteht.
Q&A-Debatte, das kommt natürlich jetzt hier auch noch mal mit rein.
Aber eben was reine Infrastruktur betrifft, ist das eben jetzt auch schon ein
ganz wichtiges Ding. Und jetzt wird ist auf einmal auch militärisch wichtig.
Das ist sozusagen das, was jetzt allen gerade klar zu werden scheint,
aber es wird halt noch eine Weile dauern, bis wir da Lückenschluss betreiben können.
Weil die einzigen großen Contender, die derzeit unterwegs sind,
sind halt neben SpaceX, Amazon, auch dann eine Infrastruktur,
also das Käupersystem ist im Prinzip die gleiche Idee wie Starlink.
Und OneWeb, was ein britisches Unternehmen ist. Das ist zwar im Prinzip Europa,
aber halt jetzt nicht so Europa, wie die EU das gerne hätte.
Naja, und wir haben es ja auch in der EU immer wieder mit Leuten zu tun,
die Internet generell nicht verstanden haben, deswegen bin ich da auch jetzt nicht so optimistisch.
Gucken wir mal.
Ja, das dazu. Und Elon Musk soll einfach mal Fresse halten. Der Typ,
der geht mir einfach so dermaßen auf den Senkel.
Es ist einfach wirklich... Ich meine, was ist mit dem irgendwie?
Ist der irgendwie von Alien-Bakterien besetzt worden? Oder oder so,
als ich verstehe, das ist einfach nicht mehr so.
Ich glaube, man sollte auch nicht versuchen, das zu verstehen.
Du kannst ja vielleicht Chat-GPT fragen, ob es dir das erklären kann.
Dazu kommen wir noch.
Das machen wir noch. Lass mal weiter machen.
Ja, kommen wir doch zu anderen Katastrophen.
Die letzte Generation, das sind die Menschen, die sich an Straßen kleben.
Ich weiß nicht, Was machen die sonst noch so? Also auf jeden Fall sehr krasse
Protestform, würde ich sagen.
Weiß ich nicht, wie du das wahrnimmst.
Ja, krasse Protestformen trifft es schon. Ich glaube zwar nicht unbedingt,
dass sie den Zeitgeist so immer richtig treffen und dass alles so produktiv
ist, was sie machen, aber es ist natürlich auch eine Wahl des Widerstandes.
Ja, also ich glaube schon. Ich glaube, seit Extinction Rebellion sind die schon
die, die da am stärksten gegen vorgehen.
Extreme Krisen und nicht reagierende Politiker sind auf jeden Fall für mich
ein Grund zu extremen Maßnahmen.
Also ich glaube schon, dass das sehr wirksam ist. Die Debatte um die letzte
Generation, wie sie stattfindet, ist irgendwie bis hin zu Klima-RF ist alles dabei.
Und die Freunde von der Springerpresse haben das für eine sehr gute Idee gehalten,
dann mal eine Recherche zu veröffentlichen, die sie genannt haben Inside-letzte Generation.
Und was die aufgedeckt haben, ist, dass es über 2200 Datensätze erreichbar über eine Google Drive,
auf denen eine relativ große Gruppe Zugriff hat,
aufgezeigt haben, in denen die letzte Generation die Kontaktinformation von
Aktivisten festgehalten hat,
aber auch deren psychische Zustände, deren politische Einsatzbereitschaft und
sehr viel weitere Informationen.
Und das ist natürlich so ein Ding, das schreit halt nur nach,
ich sag mal, Missbrauch, im Anführungsstrichen.
Das werden halt definitiv Leute benutzen, vielleicht um Feindeslisten zu machen,
aber auch Schraferfolgungsbehörden.
Und insgesamt ist die Situation um die letzte Generation sehr erhitzt.
Das ist eigentlich interessant, weil so etwas Ähnliches hatte Extinction Rebellion auch schon mal geplant.
Und zwar in Form von einem Fragebogen, den sie dann sehr kurzfristig zurückgezogen
haben von ein paar Jahren und das dann doch nicht gemacht haben,
weil sie festgestellt haben, dass es vielleicht nicht so gut ist,
eine zentrale Datensammlung mit diesen Informationen über ihre Aktivistie zu haben.
Mhm.
Und.
Verstehe ich. Das hat natürlich eine Riesendebatte darüber ausgelöst,
was denen einfiel, dass die als Gegendatenschutz verstoßen und so weiter und so fort.
Ich glaube auch da, ich habe immer so ein bisschen das Gefühl,
dass wir die Hacker und alle anderen Bewegungen vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen
mehr zusammenarbeiten müssten.
Also ich habe das Gefühl, dass einige Bewegungen einfach nicht die Kapazitäten
haben, sich zu überlegen oder sich damit zu beschäftigen, was für so eine technische
Infrastruktur sie sich da jetzt hinstellen müssen oder was sie machen müssen,
um ordentlich Obseck zu machen und so weiter.
Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass das deren Expertise sein muss,
aber ich glaube, dass wir jetzt vielleicht sogar die Expertise hätten,
um denen dabei zu helfen.
Das ist für mich von mir ein Wunsch, aber um nochmal auf die letzte Generation zurückzukommen.
Ich finde das sehr krass, wie die jetzt für dieses Ding angegangen werden und
das sehr stark individualisiert wird.
Und das ist so eine krasse Doppelmoderal,
die immer sehr stark nur auf Aktivistie angewandt wird,
wenn jetzt irgendwie keine Ahnung gefühlt irgendeine große Firma X die Personaldaten
in der Google Drive an weiß ich nicht wie viele Leute freigegeben hätte,
dann wäre da sicherlich weniger los in der öffentlichen Debatte.
Also das finde ich schon hart.
Ja klar, ich meine die großen Unternehmen die versuchen ja auch nicht gleich
das ganze System zu stürzen.
Das ist ja klar.
Das kann man jetzt so oder so sehen.
Ja gut, also ich meine, das so eine Aktivistengruppe, gerade mit dieser Prämisse,
mit alles muss sich ändern, von vielen Besitzstandswarern.
Quasi als eine Gefährdung ihres Lebens oder Geschäftsmodells angesehen wird.
Das ist ja keine Neuigkeit und letzten Endes ist es ja auch das Selbstverständnis
eigentlich dieser Gruppe.
Dementsprechend macht man sich natürlich dann auch viele Feinde und dann muss
man natürlich noch mal extra drauf achten, dass man sich auch nicht unbedingt
unnötig angreifbar macht und mit so einer Aktion macht man das natürlich.
Jetzt kann ich natürlich verstehen, dass das irgendwie in gewisser Hinsicht
auch so ein Pragmatismus ist,
der dann eben zu so einer Leichtsinnigkeit führt, der dann eben gepaart mit
der mangelnden Kompetenz in diesen Bereichen dann eben so eine Sache hervorbringt.
Und natürlich hätten die das besser machen müssen und natürlich hätte man da
irgendwie sehr viel mehr Infrastruktur machen können, aber wie das eben so ist,
das ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt so der Fokus dieser Gruppe.
Das Problem ist natürlich, dann kaum passiert es dann so und gerät der Bild in die Hände.
Da muss man sich halt auch nicht wundern, dass man dann voll flack abbekommt,
weil das ist natürlich ein gefundenes Fressen für alle Gruppen,
die sich daran stören, wofür so ein Projekt steht.
Dann geht es natürlich voll drauf. Klar.
Ja, klar. Also wie gesagt, ich plädiere immer noch dafür, dass wir alle ein
bisschen mehr zusammenarbeiten müssen und dann die Leute, die die Kapazitäten
und Kompetenzen in dem Bereich haben, auch die Sachen zur Verfügung stellen.
Ich weiß nicht, habt ihr solche Zusammenarbeiten in der Vergangenheit?
Du bist ja schon ein bisschen länger dabei als ich.
Naja, sagen wir mal so, der Kongress hat ja in den letzten Jahren sehr dazu
geführt, dass sich solche Szenen besser vermischen.
Und da es nur diesen Kongress auch schon seit drei Jahren nicht mehr gibt,
ist das natürlich auch alles ein bisschen eingeschlafen.
Also ich sage jetzt nicht, dass es jetzt keine Aktivität mehr gibt und sozusagen
da überhaupt nichts mehr stattfindet. Aber das war natürlich schon so ein befruchtendes Moment.
Und deswegen braucht es halt solche Veranstaltungen auch wieder gehäuft.
Definitiv. Ja, das ist alles irgendwie nicht so einfach mit dem Datenschutz und allem.
Ja. Das ist auch dem Bund aufgefallen, dass das alles nicht so einfach ist.
Oder vielleicht ist es Ihnen nicht so aufgefallen, aber es wird auf jeden Fall immer wieder deutlich.
Ihnen ist es nicht so aufgefallen, anderen Leuten schon. Ich bin auch eine Person,
die davon betroffen ist. Und zwar hat die Bundesregierung ja beschlossen,
dass Studierende einen Energiekostenzuschuss bekommen sollen.
Das ist eine Einmal-Auszahlung von 200 Euro.
Und die muss man natürlich auch beantragen. So. Und wie das so ist,
Bildung ist ja eigentlich Ländersache.
Das heißt, die Bundesregierung hat so einen Topf zur Verfügung gestellt und
gesagt, okay, hier Länder, ihr müsst jetzt gucken, wie ihr das macht.
Und dann haben die Länder gesagt, ja, okay, Bund, mach du doch mal lieber.
Und hat das Bundesministerium für Bildung und Forschung, das BF,
damit beauftragt, ein Antragsportal dafür zu bauen.
Das haben die auch gemacht und damit das dann auch genutzt werden kann auf Länderebene,
müssen die das auch bekannt geben. Deswegen hat das BMBF eine Musterverordnung
gebaut und das hätten die Länder dann bekannt geben können.
So und wie funktioniert dieses Antragsportal jetzt?
Das ist gekoppelt an die ein BundID Servicekonto und das Servicekonto oder diese
BundID ist so ein ähnlicher Service wie die D-Mail.
Weil?
Weil das zu der Umsetzung des E-Government-Gesetzes führt, also dass die Zugänge
zu bestimmten Sachen anbieten müssen, die digital sind.
Deswegen gehört das sozusagen sagen, mit in diese Familie der Dinge,
die der Bund gemacht hat.
Und kann man sich aber so vorstellen wie Login with Google. Also man kann sich
so eine Bund-ID beantragen und kann das dann zum Einloggen benutzen.
Und bei diesem Antragsportal braucht man eine Bund-ID oder eine Elster. Heißt ist das auch ID?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das funktioniert mit diesen Elster-Sachen,
aber du bist ja Buchhaltungsexperte, du weißt das schon, oder?
Ja, also ein Elster-Zertifikat ist das sozusagen.
Also du brauchst halt quasi eine steuerbezogene Legitimierung und die drückt
sich dann in der Regel in der Zuteilung eines Zertifikats mit dem man sich dann einloggt.
Also es gibt verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Okay, was ist das für ein Zertifikat?
Na so eine Zertifikatsdatei, wobei du auch bei Elstar dich über verschiedenste
andere Wege einloggen kannst. Also es gibt da jetzt irgendwie auch irgendwie
auch neuen Kram mit irgendwie QR-Code Login und so ein komischen Elstar-App.
Das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert, das klingt ganz furchtbar.
Man kann theoretisch sich auch mit seinem Personalausweis einloggen,
mit der tollen Ausweis-App 2.
Einen Namen für den sie gestraft gehören, mehrfach.
Aber warum heißt die eigentlich so, weil sie den anderen Namen nicht mehr bekommen haben?
Ich glaube, also ich weiß es nicht mehr so ganz. Also warum,
das kann ich dir nicht wirklich erklären, weil das kann einfach,
das ist einfach, das allein dafür gehört, irgendjemand geteert und gefedert.
Ja, also ich meine, ich meine mich zu erinnern, dass es irgendwie tatsächlich
mal eine Ausweis-App gab und die dann gelöscht wurde und dann haben sie eine
andere in den App Store geladen und die hieß dann zwei, weil die andere war
ja schon weg. Also irgendein Düsselkram.
So und jetzt kann man es irgendwie nicht mehr erinnern, weil es steht ja überall.
Aber es gibt sozusagen verschiedenste Möglichkeiten, sich gegenüber A-Star auszuweisen.
Wie viel davon verwendet wird, ich würde mal vermuten, der Großteil der Leute
benutzt einfach das ganz normale, die ganz normale Zertifikatsdatei.
Da muss man sich dann einmal mit seiner Steuernummer anmelden und dann kriegt
man das quasi an seinen finanzabgemeldeten Ort per Post geschickt.
Und ja, du darfst. Und dann musst du das eingeben und dann kannst du deine Zertifikatsdatei
runterladen. Und ja, ist alles ein bisschen elend, aber zumindest funktioniert Das war's für heute.
Okay, gut. Also diese Option gibt es auf jeden Fall auch.
Und das hat relativ viele Probleme, also unabhängig davon, dass das User-Interface
ein bisschen broken ist und dass das alles mega seltsam aussieht.
Und so, also das ist so eine Sache, aber das ist jetzt bei so Projekten der
Bundesregierung nicht so überraschend.
Aber eigentlich ist es halt so, du kannst, Es gibt keine andere Möglichkeit
außer Bund.ID oder dem Zertifikat, das Ding zu beantragen.
Und wenn, ich glaube auch noch mit der Ausweis-App 2, aber dann auch noch mit
irgendeinem, ich kriege es nicht mehr zusammen, es ist auf jeden Fall relativ,
also es geht eigentlich nur mit einem elektronischen Identitätsnachweis.
Was ja eigentlich für so ein deutsches Ding relativ spannend ist,
weil normalerweise ist das ja auch manchmal ein bisschen andersrum.
Heißt aber für alle Leute, die irgendwie keine Papiere haben oder was auch immer,
kein NFC-fähiges Gerät oder oder oder schwierig.
Und das nächste Problem, was wir haben, ist natürlich, dass wir jetzt so eine
riesen Datenbank bauen.
Weil das BMBF hat zwar dieses Antragsportal gebaut,
hat aber jetzt nicht gesagt, okay, jedes Land hat seine Datenbank,
so wie es ja eigentlich wäre, wenn die Länder das selber Regeln,
sondern die sammeln jetzt sozusagen alle diese Anträge an einer zentralen Stelle.
Und das ist natürlich eigentlich ein Verschmuss gegen die Datenschutzgrundverordnung, die wir da haben.
Ist das so, dass jetzt so wirklich G sammeln, also ich meine,
wenn der Bund das sowieso zahlt, ist das dann nicht eigentlich auch total Schnuppe?
Ne, ne, also der Bund hat einen Topf gebaut,
der dann an die Länder geht und die Länder zahlen das dann sozusagen aus,
weil Bildung, Ländersache, Studierende, Bildung und so.
Genau. Also das bildet sich halt so eine zentralisierte Datenbank,
du hast keine Datentrennung mehr,
du eigentlich haben könntest und so weiter
und so fort also das ist alles nicht so doll und du
kannst eigentlich aussuchen ob du entweder das haben
willst oder frieren das sind so die
option die man da hat als student ja also ich meine wie würde man es denn sonst
also ich meine man kann mit elsa zertifikat reingehen das haben jetzt in der
regel nur leute die in irgendeiner Form,
sagen wir mal, gehoben steuerlich aktiv sind.
Also Selbstständige und alle Leute, die sozusagen ihre Einkommensteuererklärungen
noch zusätzlich machen, obwohl sie das nicht unbedingt müssen.
Wie viele das sind? Weiß nicht. Vermutlich sind so einige. Studenten gehören
jetzt meistens zu den Leuten,
die sowas nicht haben, weil man ist ja noch nicht so wirtschaftlich aktiv,
deswegen fällt es weg, also musst du irgendwas anderes haben und dazu brauchst
du halt irgendwas, was dich ausweist.
Ich meine, das nicht online zu machen, ist ja irgendwie auch Käse.
Naja, aber was ich mich halt frage ist ja, also Universitäten haben ja die Daten ihrer Studierenden.
Also so grundsätzlich. Wieso kann man das nicht zum Beispiel?
Also ich glaube, ein sehr großer Teil der Studierenden schafft,
wird dieses, diese Energiekosten, diesen Energiekostenzuschuss bekommen.
Ich glaube sogar fast alle.
Wieso kann man sich nicht so was wie überlegen, wie man legt es einfach auf
die Studiengebühren zum Beispiel um?
Ja, das Problem ist, dass du dann wiederum schlecht eine Rückmeldung bekommst.
Wann wird das ausgezahlt, wer hat das jetzt schon irgendwie erhalten?
Ja, aber das ist ja nicht so kompliziert bei der Energiekostenpauschale.
Und ganz ehrlich, Studiengebühren sind irgendwie zum 15. Februar fällig.
Und wenn die dann halt 200 Euro weniger sind, dann hast du ja also schon...
Ist denn das, sind in allen Ländern jetzt Studiengebühren so ein fester Bestandteil,
die größer als 200 Euro sind?
Ja, Studiengebühren liegen inzwischen im Bereich um so 345 Euro. Das war's für heute.
Und die sind überall. Also das ist ja sozusagen irgendwie so dein Öffi-Ticket,
dir Asterbeitrag, der Verwaltungsbeitrag.
Okay, aber diese Einmalzahlung betrifft Studierende, aber auch Berufsfachschülerinnen und Fachschüler.
Mhm. So. Aber, gucken wir mal.
Da hast du dann wieder sozusagen noch mal so eine andere Gruppe.
Und ich will das jetzt hier gar nicht schönreden.
Ich sag nur, das ist wahrscheinlich ein bisschen der Gedanke auch,
weil letzten Endes, was ja der Idealfall wäre, so kriegt einfach jeder.
Und es wird ja eben von was auch immer abgezogen.
Ja, natürlich. Und dann hast du das Problem nicht.
Genau. Aber so jeder ist halt auch schwer zu definieren.
Und ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, ob diese Einmalzahlung dann wieder pro Haushalt
ist oder wirklich pro Person. Also wahrscheinlich sind irgendwie haushaltsbezogen.
Wir sind einfach generell digital zu schlecht aufgestellt, um solche Sachen mal eben zu wuppen.
Ich meine, auf der anderen Seite jetzt für Leute, die Angestellte sind,
da ist es dann eben quasi einfach über den normalen Gehaltsapparat abgewickelt
worden. Mit Lohnsteuer etc.
Darüber erreiste ja dann sozusagen auch die meisten Leute.
Ja, also dieses, da eine zentralisierte Plattform zu bauen und dann auch noch
zu sagen, also Du kannst dich nur mit der Scheiß-Identifizierungsoption identifizieren.
Jetzt mal überspitzt gesagt. Ist halt suboptimal und das ist jetzt sehr,
also war tatsächlich auch in den Kommentaren nach der letzten Sendung,
sind sehr, sehr viele Studierende, die damit sehr unhappy sind.
Und es ist einfach sehr viel Aufwand.
Und fühlt sich Datenschutz technisch echt nicht gut an als Student.
Also Datenschutz technisch keine Ahnung. Ich meine, am Ende musst du dich ja
identifizieren. Du willst irgendwie Geld vom Staat haben, sondern musst halt
sagen, hallo, hier bin ich, gib mir mein Geld.
Was willst du da groß schützen jetzt an Daten?
Aber wie gesagt, die Unis haben die Daten, die können auch Codes raussenden.
Also so, kommen wir wieder zurück zu der Sache. Wenn ich meinen Studierendenbeitrag bezahlt habe und,
Dann kriege ich eben Bestätigungsschreiben von der Uni, dass jetzt da noch ein
Zettel zuzulegen ist jetzt nicht so aufwendig.
Ja gut, aber das ist wie gesagt, dann hast du wieder Berufsschüler,
die sind in einem ganz anderen System drin.
Nein, aber die sind ja auch in der Schule aus, also die Berufsschüler haben
ja zum Beispiel auch eigentlich Arbeitgeber.
Ja gut, aber dann bist du, also sag mal,
ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob das jetzt wirklich der Weg ist,
Weil eigentlich sind diese ganzen anderen Wege,
sind ja in gewisser Hinsicht dann eben auch immer alles nur Umwege,
die dann wieder durch eine andere Verwaltungsstruktur durchgehen müssen,
wo die Leute dann auch auf einmal mit 200 Euro Zahlungen beschäftigt sind,
die eigentlich was ganz anderes zu tun haben und dann das nicht irgendwie richtig
machen und dann irgendwelche Datenbankextrakte aus ihrem Kontext herausliefern
müssen, während man es eigentlich zentral lösen muss. Und insofern finde ich das gut.
Das Problem hier, glaube ich, ist eher, dass diese Bund-ID einfach nichts ist,
was irgendjemand schon mal vorher jemals gehört hat.
So, ehrlich gesagt, ich auch nicht.
Ich wusste nicht, dass es das gibt und finde das jetzt mal interessant und werde mal versuchen,
mir mal eine anzulegen, weil das bedeutet ja im Prinzip, ich muss mich in irgendeiner
Form, gut, man hat das vielleicht mit meinem ELSA-Zertifikat jetzt ein bisschen
leichter, ja, weil das würde ich jetzt wahrscheinlich nehmen.
Zweite Geschichte wäre das halt mit diesem Personalausweis.
Das weiß ich, dass das auf meinem Telefon auch funktioniert.
So grundsätzlich funktioniert es schon. Das habe ich jetzt irgendwie mal hinbekommen.
Ich weiß aber auch, wie unzugänglich das für die allermeisten Leute ist.
So das ist einfach, weil es einfach alles zu awkward ist, zu viele Fehlerstricke hat.
Der ganze Prozess ist einfach null gestreamt, gestreamt leid.
Und das ist halt das, woran eigentlich gearbeitet werden muss.
Das ist ein Prozess, der wird noch lange dauern.
Aber im Prinzip finde ich den Weg richtig, dass wir einfach eine Kontaktstelle herstellen zum Staat.
Sagen hallo, guten Tag, ich bin's dein Bürger.
Ich log mich mal hier ein über einen leicht zu bedienenden, nachvollziehbaren
Prozess, der der Sache angemessen ist.
Und dann kommt die Webseite und da steht, was du alles machen kannst,
irgendwie mit deinem Staat.
So und dann klickst du an so ja hier einmal Zahlung irgendwie 200 Euro, zack hätte ich gern.
Übrigens würde ich gerne auch noch das, das, das. Hier möchte ich noch mein
Auto anmelden, hier möchte ich irgendwie gerne noch meine Steuer einreichen,
hier möchte ich gerne irgendwie diesen Antrag stellen.
Das muss alles so laufen, weil das funktioniert in anderen Staaten schon so.
Und es gibt überhaupt gar keinen anderen Weg als den.
Der muss irgendwie erreicht werden. Also ich glaube, dass es sich hier im Wesentlichen
eher um ein Problem des User Interfaces handelt,
das einfach nicht gelöst worden ist, weil wir einfach noch kein gelungenes Verhältnis
haben zwischen Bürger und dem digitalen Staat, weil es diesen digitalen Staat
einfach so in der Form noch nicht überall gibt.
Und der poppt jetzt hier und da auf und man versucht solche Vorgänge auch zu
nutzen, um diese Beziehungen herzustellen.
Das finde ich ja an sich, finde ich das ja irgendwie ganz gut.
Und ehrlich gesagt, ich sehe dieses Datenschutzproblem hier eher als totalen Nebenaspekt.
Weil ehrlich gesagt, welche Daten sollen, also wer, wessen Zugriff auf welche
Daten sollen jetzt hier irgendwie geschützt werden? Ich will die Cola haben.
Ich melde mich an, ich sage hier hallo, ich bin empfangsberechtigt.
Gib her. Ja, so, ich mein, das ist der ganze Flow der Stadt, wo ich eh wirklich bin.
Naja, also ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen komplizierter als das.
Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass es nur das User Interface ist,
an dem es scheitert, sondern auch, dass der ganze klare Radatsch,
der dahinter hängt, fucked up ist.
Und ich meine, wir haben das ja bei den zentralisierten Corona-Warn-Apps gerade
erst gesehen, was passiert, wenn es solche zentralen Datensammlungen gibt.
Und dann zentrale Datensammlungen gone wrong passiert.
Und ich glaube, dieses Risiko ist einfach inherent, das ist da.
Und ja, ich glaube, wir sehen das auch in dieser ganzen E-Hidas-Debatte.
Also wenn du dir diese erste technische Konzeptionierung oder Standard,
den sie da veröffentlicht haben, angeguckt hast, dann möchtest du eigentlich
nur in der Ecke sitzen und weinen.
Sie kriegen es halt nicht ordentlich hin.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja was ich meine mit User Interface. Ich rede ja jetzt
nicht von der Webseite und wo der Button ist oder so, sondern ich meine das
komplette Bürger-Staatsschnittstelle.
Das ist sozusagen mein User. Ich bin ja ein Staats-User. Ich will ja diesen Staat usen.
Ich gebe dem ja auch eine ganze Menge Geld, damit er irgendwie Dienstleistungen
für mich bereitstellt, so in Form von Straßen und allem möglichen Scheiß.
Und bestimmte Dienstleistungen Erfordern halt auch eine interaktion wie zum
beispiel die abgabe meiner steuer erklärung oder eben auch dass sie in anspruch
nehmen bestimmter Sondervorgänge wie zum Beispiel jetzt diese Einmalzahlung.
Das muss dem Staat gelingen, das sowohl einfach, datenschutzrechtlich natürlich
auch unbedenklich und technisch natürlich auch sicher durchzuführen.
Ich sage nicht, dass das einfach ist, aber es ist auch nicht unmöglich.
Selbstverständlich ist es möglich und es ist vor allem absolut erforderlich.
Und ich finde es durchaus begrüßenswert, dass es jetzt in diese Richtung geht.
Und mir ist vollkommen klar, dass dieser Staat noch 50 mal gegen die Glaswand
laufen wird und sich dabei eine blutige Nase holen wird.
Aber das ist mir ehrlich gesagt immer noch lieber, als ob nichts passiert.
So und jetzt kann man sich natürlich da verweigern und sagen so,
ja nee, mir ist das aber alles zu kompliziert und ich will gerne mein Papierformular
auswählen und irgendwie das Bargeld über den Counter geschoben bekommen.
Aber ich glaube, da sind wir uns auch irgendwie einig, die Zeiten müssen jetzt
auch langsam mal vorbei sein.
Ja, also ich glaube, worum es hier geht, ist ein bisschen was anderes.
Du hast das vorhin irgendwie schon ganz schön gesagt, dass du halt weißt,
wie du deine coole Ausweis-2-App benutzt und du auch weißt, wie du dein Älsterzertifikat
in die Kamera hältst, hätte ich fast gesagt.
Aber für die meisten Studierenden ist es halt nicht so trivial,
aber der Leidensdruck, diese 200 Euro Energiepauschale zu bekommen, ist halt sehr hoch.
Und das dann an so einer Stelle einzuschrauben, wo wir eh mit dem Rücken an
die Wand stehen, ist halt nicht so cool.
Also das ist, glaube ich, das, worum es in dieser ganzen Debatte geht,
dass wir nicht mehr Bargeld am Counter abholen wollen.
Das ist nochmal eine ganz andere Geschichte. Aber ich finde es ja prinzipiell begrüßenswert,
wenn die gegen Glastürnen rennen wollen, aber bitte nicht auf den Rücken von
armen Studierenden, die nicht wissen, ob sie nächste eine warme Wohnung haben oder nicht.
Also das finde ich halt einfach echt maximal.
Und cool. Ist aber jetzt auch ein kleiner Intelligenztest, muss ich sagen,
für das studierende Volk. Ich meine, das ist ja...
Ja, cool. So...
Die Außerwählten, da müssen wir jetzt auch mal ein bisschen anstrengen, ja.
Mit kalten Füßen und leeren Magen lassen sich so Intelligenztests immer besonders gut lösen.
Ja, ich bin jetzt ein bisschen fies, aber es muss...
Ja, ja, alles gut.
Alle Seiten müssen sich hier ein bisschen am Riemen reißen.
Können ja nicht alle irgendwie Boomer mit drei Wohnungen sein. Genau.
Gut, let's move on.
Let's move on zu anderen Verboten.
Was haben wir denn noch?
Naja, noch mehr aus dem Masken-Grußekampinett. Wie viele Mask-Tweets hast du
diese Woche eigentlich gesehen? Gesendet? Geseh- Geseh- Geseh- Weiß ich was.
Du bist der Ohrheber von diesen ganzen pubertärenden Memes.
Ehrlich gesagt keine, weil ich dem Typen nicht folge und kann sogar sein,
dass ich ihn geblockt habe. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Naja wahrscheinlich hast du ihn geblockt, weil er hat den Algorithmus jetzt
so angepasst, dass es in deiner For You Page immer, wenn er was tweetet,
als Allererstes auftaucht.
Ja, For You Page. Ja, so einen Quatsch benutze ich ja nicht.
Also für mich war ja, also Twitter ist jetzt für mich eigentlich schon tot und
der einzige Grund warum ich das jetzt überhaupt noch,
warum ich überhaupt noch eine Twitter App habe, die ich vorher so nicht gehabt
habe, die muss ich ja jetzt haben, weil meine, weil mein Tweetbot nicht mehr
funktioniert und ich habe auch festgestellt, ich habe gar nicht Twitter benutzt
die letzten Jahre, ich habe eigentlich Tweetbot benutzt.
Tweetbot war eigentlich mein Netzwerk. Ja, ich auch.
So und jetzt wo ich feststelle, wie die anderen das alle benutzen,
wundere ich mich, warum es diesen Dienst überhaupt noch gibt.
Also das ist ja vollkommen unzumutbar und das geht ja überhaupt nicht.
Diese Webseite habe ich so ab und zu mal benutzt um einen Tweet zu schreiben,
weil es gerade nicht anders ging oder weil es da einfacher war das am Computer
zu tun als in der App aus irgendwelchen Gründen, weil irgendein Button da nicht
auftauchte oder weil irgendein Feature für die App nicht freigeschaltet war.
Aber ansonsten habe ich damit nichts zu tun gehabt. Aber diese App,
das geht ja nur wirklich überhaupt nicht. Also das ist für mich jetzt vorbei.
Das einzige Problem ist nur, dass ich leider noch nicht in anderen Netzen dieselben
Informationsquellen erhalte, weil da noch nicht alle bereit sind,
die Plattform zu verlassen.
Der gute Netzwerkeffekt kommt jetzt hier wieder voll zum Tragen.
Und zum Beispiel jetzt so Informationen über den Krieg in der Ukraine,
dem ich halt irgendwie doch relativ intensiv noch folge, gibt es halt so.
Gut, ich könnte jetzt komplett auf Telegram-Channel wechseln,
so das wäre die andere Variante, ist aber auch nicht ganz so meine Geschmacksrichtung
und von daher suche ich gerade händeringend nach Lösungen, das sozusagen noch zu bridgen.
Aber grundsätzlich denke ich mal, ist es durch.
Ich muss dir sagen, die Marstonon-App von den Menschen, die den Tweetbot gebaut
haben, ist tatsächlich sehr schön.
Listen auf Mastodon funktionieren noch nicht so gut leider.
Genau, also Listen sind eigentlich das große Problem. Ivory,
also wer das nicht mitbekommen hat, also Tweetbot ist ja quasi,
war schon immer so die eine von den beiden besten Apps, mit denen man Twitter
überhaupt benutzen kann.
So und jetzt wo die ganzen Zeit Partyclients gekillt worden sind,
müssen die sich natürlich auch überlegen, was sie machen.
Der eine Anbieter von Twitterrific, die hatten schon immer auch noch andere
Apps, aber Tweetbot war für die Bude. Wie heißt die noch gleich?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie die heißen. Deswegen sage ich immer die Menschen,
die den Tweetbot gebaut haben.
Ja, jetzt habe ich es gerade von Tapbots.
Genau, und für Tapbots war das halt das große Ding. Und jetzt haben sie halt
für Masterladen irgendwie Ivory rausgebracht, was quasi das alte Tweetboard
User Interface und App Grundgerüst ist, bloß eben mit der anderen Infrastruktur darunter.
Das funktioniert auch total super. Ich benutze das irgendwie auch schon auf dem.
Telefon, aber auf meinem Mac noch nicht, Und wenn du sozusagen dieselben Quellen
nicht bekommst, dann kann so ein Netzwerk das halt nicht ohne weiteres ersetzen.
Ja und vor allen Dingen das Scraping von den Quellen funktioniert jetzt auch
nicht mehr, weil sie die APIs in allen Formen abgeschaltet haben.
Genau, das ist nämlich jetzt die eigentliche Nachricht, die jetzt noch dazugekommen
ist. Also wir hatten ja den Fall, dass bestimmte Third-Party-Clients abgeschaltet
wurden. Es wurden ja nicht alle abgeschaltet.
Und das ist insofern jetzt nochmal ein technisches Detail, weil es gibt ja quasi
zwei grundsätzliche Arten und
Weisen in dieses Netzwerk Tweets abzusetzen oder daraus zu konsumieren.
Man verwendet irgendeine App oder man verwendet direkt diese API,
die sie bereitgestellt haben. Das benutzen halt viele.
Es gibt also viele automatisierte Systeme, die quasi wie Bots funktionieren
und die über diese AP zugreifen.
Tut natürlich letzten Endes auch die Twitter App, aber natürlich ist Twitter
ihre eigene App bekannt.
Und diese ganzen anderen vielen kleinen Apps sind halt irgendwie so ein Wildwuchs,
die halt irgendwas tun und die größeren Apps haben sie halt so genehmigt,
aber die mussten auch schon dafür bezahlen. So was wie Tweetbot.
Die Populären sind halt jetzt alle gekillt worden und jetzt gab es so die Ansage
mit wir wollen euch nicht mehr haben, damit waren die dann vorbei.
Und dann kam jetzt noch die zweite Ansage hinterher, ach so,
übrigens und auch alle anderen, die die API jetzt benutzen und die nicht offizielle
Twitter Apps sind, ihr müsst jetzt irgendwie Geld zahlen.
Und in einer Woche wird das irgendwie umgesetzt. Gab es natürlich wieder einen
Riesenaufschrei, weil natürlich Twitter auch von Tausenden Subbots bespielt
wird von so was weiß ich irgendwie.
Ich poste einen Frame aus dem Film der Pate irgendwie über die nächsten fünf
Jahre und so. Leute dann irgendwie abonniert.
Memecounts, all dieser ganze Kram. Und die haben dann alle gesagt,
so ja, habt ihr sie noch alle? Ich zahle jetzt nicht für den Scheiß,
ich mache das hier in meiner Freizeit. Das ist hier ein Spaßprojekt.
Wir gehen. So. Dann haben sie wieder kalte Füße bekommen bei Twitter,
wie das immer so ist. Erst kündigen sie irgendwas an. Drei Tage später ist wieder alles anders.
Und jetzt haben sie halt so gesagt, naja, okay, gut, wir machen es dann doch
nicht kostenpflichtig für alle, sondern ihr habt so ein Mindestkontingent an so und so viele Tweets.
Das sind dann irgendwie, 1500 pro Monat oder so sind irgendwie frei.
Wenn ihr darüber hinaus was wollt, dann müsst ihr irgendwie bezahlen.
Das kostet 100 Dollar im Monat oder so was.
Aber dass Sie Geld nehmen für Ihre API, damit habe ich überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Ihre Dienstleistung, irgendwie ist Ihre Infrastruktur klar. Also wenn Sie der
Meinung sind, das wäre irgendwas wert, dann sollen Sie das machen.
Aber dann auch bitte weniger Werbung machen, wenn Sie schon Geld für solche...
Ja, das ist ja nochmal eine andere Diskussion. Aber generell so dieses,
du kannst einen Nutzen aus aus unserem Netzwerk, so wie es ist,
so dann zahlst du jetzt auch irgendwie Geld. Das kann man ja machen.
Das ist ja alles völlig in Ordnung.
Nur das dann irgendwie so eine Woche vorher anzukündigen.
So ja, irgendwie euer Businessmodell, auf das ihr euch jetzt irgendwie mit euren
Venture-Kapitalisten geeinigt habt und so weiter, ist jetzt alles Bogus.
Oder wir lassen eure Apps einfach sterben, so von heute auf morgen.
Wir schalten es auch erst mal ab und dann sagen wir erst mal drei Tage lang gar nichts.
Dann geben wir irgendwelche dusseligen Statements raus, die nicht stimmen.
Und dann eine Woche später ändern wir unsere Regeln, die das belegen,
was jetzt irgendwie vor einer Woche schon durchgesetzt wurden.
Und dann äußern wir uns vielleicht irgendwann dazu. Also es ist einfach völlig
Hanebüchen, wie dieser Laden mit der Öffentlichkeit und vor allem mit seinen
eigenen Kunden, Geschäftspartnern, wie auch immer, wie man es nennen soll,
Usern vor allem auch umgeht.
Und das ist halt einfach genau das, was einfach das Vertrauen in diese Plattformen
komplett erodiert hat. Also ich meine, ich war ja auch noch am Anfang so der
Meinung mit so, naja, der will ja damit irgendwie auch Geld verdienen und so.
Aber mittlerweile weiß ich überhaupt nicht, was den treibt.
Naja, aber das zeigt ja auch irgendwie ganz gut so das Problem von großen Social-Media-Plattformen,
die so einem so Wahnsinnigen gehören, dass die auch einfach teilweise tickende Zeitbomben sind,
aber irgendwie auch kritische Infrastruktur, weil wir das irgendwie alle benutzen,
weiß nicht, sowohl als Quelle für jeden, für alles Mögliche,
als auch als Kommunikationsmedium, Plattform, was auch immer und dann hat er
einen Line zu viel gezogen, dieser Wahnsinnige.
Und dann ist halt einfach alles tot. So, boom.
Wo man dann auch mal hinterfragen muss, so wollen wir so einen zentralisierten
Social Media Scheiß eigentlich überhaupt noch haben oder wollen wir jetzt mal draus lernen?
Aber das ist noch mal eine ganz andere Frage.
Ja, ich meine, das zentralisierte Modell ist natürlich technisch sehr naheliegend,
weil es sich ja hier quasi um ein Netzwerk handelt und in dem Moment,
wo du das an einer Stelle pflegst, ist es jetzt technisch hast du natürlich Vorteile davon.
Das sieht man ja auch an dem dezentralen Activity-Pub-basierten Massadon-Netzwerk,
dass da eben sich nicht alles ohne weiteres auch mit realisieren lässt und langfristig
muss sich das auch erst mal zeigen, ob das dezentrale Modell eher ein Vorteil
oder eher ein Nachteil ist. hat sowohl Vorteile als auch Nachteile.
Und das muss sich jetzt neu auskäsen. Und es kann sehr gut sein,
dass sich das irgendwie stabilisiert.
Und es kann auch sehr gut sein, dass es vielleicht in der Lage ist,
so ein bisschen wieder was in das offene Netz zurückzuholen,
wo bisher eigentlich nur E-Mail überlebt hat, weil das irgendwie keiner so richtig
übernommen. Ja, stimmt eigentlich auch nicht. Es gibt ja auch Gmail und so.
Aber bei diesen ganzen sozialen Netzwerken, die sind halt schon sehr stark und
da muss schon wirklich einer extrem destruktiv daherkommen, um das irgendwie
zu zerstören. Das ist irgendwie so, das schafft... Wieder ein Mask so, holt mein Starling.
Genau.
Das krieg ich hin irgendwie so, keine Ahnung. Also ich glaub,
da ist irgendwas, da ist irgendwas, irgendwas ist da kaputt gegangen bei ihm.
Also irgendwas funktioniert da nicht richtig. Ich weiß es nicht.
Oder ist es wirklich so auf eine Art und Weise evil, wie wir uns das noch gar
nicht so richtig vorstellen können. Aber es macht für mich einfach überhaupt gar keinen Sinn.
Ja, also aber was du meinst mit, ich meine, es ist das erste Mal,
dass jetzt so ein System wirklich in die Hand einer einzelnen Person kommt.
Vorher war Twitter ja zumindest noch irgendwie Aktien getragen und da gab es
ja noch eine gewisse Verpflichtung, mit der Öffentlichkeit Schritt zu halten.
Das hat ja mehr oder weniger hingeworfen.
Ich meine, wenn du dir mal Facebook anguckst, gut, das hat sich jetzt in eine
andere Richtung entwickelt, aber theoretisch ist das ja auch ein bisschen so.
Und wenn man ganz genau hinguckt, ist das halt zwar nicht in der Hand jetzt von einer Person,
aber in der Hand von einem sehr homogenen Personenkreis,
der irgendwie heißt, middle-aged, Elite-Universitätsabschluss-Inhaber,
die alles bestimmen und auch ihre Vorstellung von Content-Moderationen und allem
Möglichen auf die Nutzerinnen forsten.
Auch wenn einem das vielleicht nicht ganz so stark auffallen mag wie bei Twitter,
aber so sehr unterschwellig ist es doch sehr bestimmt von der Weltsicht von
diesen primären Männern.
Klar, bei Mask zeigt sich jetzt, was passiert, wenn das eskaliert und auch in
eine böse Richtung eskaliert.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob dieses unterschwellige, trotzdem Dasein und Daseinde
und Akzeptierte nicht genauso schlimm ist, aber die User ein bisschen weniger aufregt.
Ja gut, ich meine, es gibt natürlich auch noch andere Modelle,
so wie TikTok zum Beispiel, wo du natürlich sehr viel mehr Staatseinfluss hast.
Da weiß ich jetzt nicht so richtig, ob das jetzt die beste Alternative ist.
Und es wird spannend zu sehen, ob das Internet in der Lage ist,
sich die User und den Content wieder zurückzuholen.
Am Anfang war das ja so ein bisschen das Ideal und so die Traumvorstellungen.
Man konnte sich ja ehrlich gesagt diese ganze Zentralisierung so nicht richtig
vorstellen. Es war immer so ein bisschen der Glaube, das Internet,
das kriegt ihr nicht klein, aber das war dann doch eher eine Fehlannahme.
Und jetzt sind diese Kräfte und diese Ängste,
die jetzt hier neu hervortreten durch eben Staatskontrolle oder Privatkontrolle,
beides irgendwie nicht so geil, könnte es dazu führen, dass es zumindest in
Teilen eben so einen Umschwung gibt.
Aber das Problem ist, und das ist eigentlich das Interessante an Maseron,
dass es eben sehr schwierig ist,
diesen technischen Konsens in solchen verteilten Systemen in einer Geschwindigkeit
und in einer Stabilität und auch in so einer Selbstmodernisierung hinzubekommen.
Also Chat ist das beste Beispiel. Da gab es irgendwie so Jabber und so weiter
und das kam einfach alles nicht voran.
Und das ist dann von den ganzen privaten Messengern einfach also komplett im
Staub gelassen worden, weil die sich einfach so schnell entwickelt haben und
auch gut entwickelt haben.
Features, Security, Geschwindigkeit, alles. Die haben skaliert bis auf Millionen
Milliarden, hatten einfach geile Benutzung.
Deswegen sind die Dinger so populär bis heute noch und eigentlich auch so populär
wie noch nie. Und da konnte kein Internetstandard mithalten.
Das hat es einfach nicht geschafft.
Ne, klar. Und ich meine, Mastodon kann da auch nicht mithalten.
Also ich war jetzt irgendwie letzte Woche wieder in Brüssel.
Und Mastodon ist halt einfach ein sehr deutsches Phänomen, muss man einfach so sagen.
Also das findet hier sehr viel Anklang. Wir haben irgendwie Ministerien,
die auf Mastodon sind und so weiter und so fort.
Wobei das ja auch nochmal interessant wird, wenn die ihre eigenen Mastodon-Instanzen
haben und sich selber moderieren. Aber das ist nochmal eine ganz andere Geschichte.
Aber wenn du halt mit Leuten sprichst, die jetzt nicht deutsch sind...
Es ist immer so, ja, ich weiß, dass es Mastodon gibt, aber das war irgendwie
so gruselig von der Usability, dass ich das nicht benutzen konnte.
Ja.
So.
Ja, das stimmt ja auch so. Nur das ändert sich jetzt gerade.
Also du hast jetzt zumindest so die App-Developer, die wirklich gute Sachen
gemacht haben auf Twitter, die sind jetzt irgendwie abgerückt.
Rückt. Das kann schon eine kritische Masse sein. Für mich ist das zum Beispiel
einer der entscheidenden Faktoren überhaupt,
weil ich einfach gar nicht bereit bin jetzt irgendwie da auf Komfort zu verzichten,
der jetzt einfach seit Jahren einfach so der absolute Minimalstandard ist und
damit muss sich das Netz halt auch messen und das ist eigentlich ist es eine schöne Sache,
weil es eben diese weil es diesen Qualitätsaspekt mit in die Waagschale wirft,
wo ansonsten immer nur über so allgemeine Prinzipien formuliert wird.
Es muss frei sein, es muss unabhängig sein.
Ja, es ist alles richtig, bin ich auch voll dafür und so weiter.
Aber wenn es sich nicht benutzen lässt, dann wird es sich nicht durchsetzen.
Guck dir an, GPG, diese ganze Verschlüsselungsgeschichte, unbenutzbar.
GPG-Implementierung im Thunderbird, mein neuster Nightmare.
Ja, aber es ist alles von vornherein nur technokratisch gedacht worden und nicht vom User her.
Gerade auch in der Open Source Kultur, muss man auch mal sagen,
ist der User ja eigentlich auch immer mehr so ein Feindbild gewesen.
Ja, oder halt irgendwie so, wenn du nicht die drei Gehirnzellen hast,
da so zu benutzen, wie ich gedacht habe, dass es convenient ist zu benutzen,
dann bist du es nicht wert, das zu benutzen.
Genau, also so eine grundarrogante Haltung, auch so eine technokratische,
so nein, aber es muss aus technischen Gründen so sein und ich kann es doch benutzen
und so. Und das ist schon immer der Scorch gewesen für alles,
was irgendwie Open Source ist.
Und die Bereitschaft, so von
der Nutzung her zu denken und auch so ein bisschen loslassen zu können,
vielleicht auch bei bestimmten Prinzipien, um einfach auch schneller einen Konsens zu erzielen.
Es ist natürlich schwierig, einen Internetstandard zu haben,
wo der Konsens irgendwie lose ist.
Aber das sind vielleicht auch Wege, die sich jetzt mal langsam finden müssen,
um einfach auch konkurrenzfähig sein zu können im Bereich der Kommunikation.
Wir hatten ja hier auch schon diese ganze Debatte um Messenger-Kompatibilität,
wo die Politik überlegt, die herzustellen.
Halt einfach technisch einfach alles sehr sehr sehr schwierig herzustellen,
weil eben diese ganzen Security Aspekte und so weiter dann eben auch dagegen sprechen.
Also da bedarf es einer neuen Kreativität und da bedarf es irgendwie auch einer
einer findigeren Softwareentwicklung.
Ja und irgendwie einer Professionalisierung glaube ich auch.
Genau, was natürlich auch eine Geldfrage ist. Dann muss man sich vielleicht
auch mehr öffnen für bezahlte Software und sowas?
Naja, aber oder es ist, ich meine, es gibt ja auch so Projekte wie also den
Prototype Fund zum Beispiel oder diesen Serverntech Fund,
die halt genau sagen, okay, irgendwie Open Source ist wichtig und eigentlich
ist es total cool, dass es das gibt und es kann total irgendwie die Basis für was bilden.
Aber wir müssen da auch irgendwie Geld drauf schmeißen, weil sonst haben wir
irgendwie total überarbeitete Open Source Menschen, ne? Das ist ja auch noch
so ein Aspekt von der ganzen Geschichte.
Und klar baue ich dann vielleicht was lieber so, wie ich das gerne benutzen
möchte, als irgendwie, ich sag mal in Anführungsstrichen, Klicky Bunty und so.
Ist ja auch irgendwie logisch.
Ja, und Geld muss vielleicht manchmal auch dann doch eine Rolle spielen,
weil das verhindert dann auch Spam.
Gut, aber wollen wir mal zu so ein paar, ich glaube ich habe noch nie richtig
gute Nachrichten mitgebracht.
Du hast noch nie gute Nachrichten mitgebracht?
Kannst du jetzt den guten Nachricht-Dingel abspielen?
Und zwar hat die GFF diese Woche diverse Klagen gewonnen.
Und das ist total cool. Ich habe das in der letzten Folge berichtet,
dass sie gegen das hamburgische und das hessische Polizeigesetz geklagt haben,
was Data Mining und vor allen Dingen Palantir erlaubt hat.
Und sie haben eine Verfassungsbeschwerde erhoben und haben gewonnen,
dass die Datenauswertung durch die Polizei in Hamburg unzulässig ist und die
in Hessen sogar verfassungswidrig ist.
Wer hat gewonnen? Die GFF. Wir müssen das immer erklären.
Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte haben wir ja schon tausendmal erwähnt,
kennt ihr wahrscheinlich auch schon alle, Aber es ist glaube ich immer wieder
wichtig, nochmal genau zu erklären.
Also ein gemeinnütziger eingetragener Verein, der sich eben für die Erkämpfung
von Freiheit in der Gesellschaft engagiert.
Dort arbeiten viele kluge Leute und bemühen sich halt Sachen,
die eigentlich rechtlich klar sein sollten, dann im Zweifelsfall auch mal wirklich
durchzusetzen vor den Verfassungsgerichten, vor anderen Körpern und so eben jetzt auch hier wieder.
Genau, und die haben gewonnen, wie gesagt. Das heißt, das ist ein sehr großartiges Ergebnis.
Ich hatte das in der letzten Sendung schon mal angesprochen,
dass es nicht so umfangreich ist, wie wir uns das vielleicht wünschen würden.
Aber das Urteil sagt, dass das erst mal nicht erlaubt ist, die Verwendung von
Daten, die getrennt waren, voneinander zu verknüpfen.
Weiter heißt es da, sondern darüber hinaus in der Erlangung besonderer grundrechtsrelevanten
neuen Wissens, dass durch automatisierte Datenauswertung oder Analyse geschaffen werden kann.
Das ist eigentlich total gut, weil sie anerkennen, dass die Polizei jetzt bei
Data Mining machen darf, aber dass es dafür besonders strenge Regeln geben muss,
damit Grundrechte eingehalten und beachtet werden.
Und die nächste Sache, das weitere Verfahren war vom Bundesverwaltungsgericht,
also das davor war vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, jetzt Bundesverwaltungsgericht.
Ich glaube, ich kann nicht erklären, was die Bedeutung des Bundesverwaltungsgerichtes,
wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin. Ich glaube, du das kannst, Tim. Sonst fragst du es mich nämlich gleich.
Also, I'm not a lawyer, ne? Also das muss man ja so zu einschreien.
Mein Verständnis ist, dass das Verfassungsgericht bezieht sich halt auf Sachen,
wie der Name schon sagt, die Verfassung und das Bundesverwaltungsgericht,
alles andere sozusagen, was die eigentliche Gerichtsbarkeit ist.
Also das oberste Gericht von allem, ja genau, neben dem Arbeitsgericht,
Gerichtshof, Finanzhof und Sozialgericht, eines der fünf obersten Gerichtshöfe des Bundes.
Okay, ist fünf eine Primzahl?
Das lassen wir mal offen.
Okay, naja, ich brauche ja noch eine Lieblingsbrimzahl, deswegen dachte ich,
das war jetzt meine Hoffnung.
Fünf ist da auf jeden Fall im Rennen, würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Ich kann dir aber auch noch ein paar andere empfehlen, weil du noch Tipps brauchst.
Ich glaube, ich frage der lieber Linus, der scheint da der Experte zu sein.
Der stimmt. Der Experte zu sein.
Noch Priemzeiten, die die anderen noch nicht gefunden haben.
Vielleicht ist er der neue Krypto-Algorithmus.
Mathematisch ist er ein Wunderkind.
Deswegen kann er im Moment auch nicht, weil er dabei ist, die neuen Satellitenbahnen
für den europäischen Star Trek auszurechnen.
Genau, da muss ich gerade ein paar neue Priemzeiten ausdenken,
um den gealen Algorithmus zu killen.
Aber um nochmal zurück zu der guten Nachricht zu kommen,
also die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte hat auch vom Bundesverwaltungsgericht
geklagt und zwar gegen das BAMF,
kurz BAMF, das Bundesamt für Migration und Flüchtlinge.
Und es ist nämlich so, dass das BAMF seit 2017 Handys von Geflüchteten auslesen darf und analysieren,
wenn keine gültigen Papiere vorhanden sind.
Und das haben die bei allen Papieren gemacht und auch Vorratsdaten darüber angelegt
und dann eine große Datenbank erstellt, die bei Asylverfahren durchsucht wurde.
Und das wurde auch schon sehr häufig kritisiert.
Und die GFF hat dann zu mehreren unterschiedlichen Fällen geklagt.
Und sie haben gewonnen. Also die Auswertung dieser Handys und Geräte zur Ermittlung
und Identität der Personen war rechtswidrig und es hätten halt andere Dinge
in Betracht gezogen werden können.
Und das ist halt nicht vereinbar mit der Datenschutz-Grundverordnung und mit
der Grundrechtecharta.
Und dementsprechend hoffen wir sozusagen, dass das jetzt auch noch weitergeht.
Sie haben sich auch beim Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten darüber beschwert,
da ist noch nichts zurückgekommen.
Aber ganz grundsätzlich ist das genauso wie diese Geschichte mit dem Hamburger
und dem hessischen Polizeigesetz eine wegweisende Rechtsprechung,
die halt ganz klar sagt, dass das, was das BAMF da macht, nicht in Ordnung ist.
Und es sagt vor allem, das Smartphone ist Privatsphäre.
Und das finde ich gerade im Hinblick auf solche Ideen, wie das halt in den USA
auch teilweise gemacht wird, so du möchtest hier einreisen, dann zeige ich uns
erstmal deinen Telefon, dann gehen wir hier mal durch deine Accounts durch und so weiter.
Man wird da ja auch teilweise extrem unter Druck gesetzt.
Und ja, so was kann darüber dann eben auch abgewählt werden.
Genau, also hier vielleicht nochmal so als Zusammenhang, dass mit der Privatsphäre
ist deswegen relevant, weil das in der Grundrechtecharta tatsächlich verankert ist.
Genau, aber das sind die beiden guten Nachrichten, die ich ausnahmsweise mal
mitgebracht habe. Und Ich finde, das sind auch echt richtig gute Nachrichten.
Es ist echt schön zu sehen, dass diese Arbeit von der GFF sich in dieser Art
und Weise niederschlägt.
Also diese beiden Fälle sind auch Fälle, die für EU-Gesetzgebungs-Sachen total
relevant sind, weil im Rahmen vom AI-Act beschäftigen wir uns viel.
Also der AI-Act ist die Regulierung von AI-Systemen, beschäftigt sich auch mit
der Technologie, die an EU-Außengrenzen oder sollte sich mit der Technologie
beschäftigen, die an die Außengrenzen zum Einsatz kommt.
Das heißt, das ist ein sehr gutes Beispiel dafür, dass das halt einfach nicht
in Ordnung ist, solche Technologien einzusetzen.
Und ja, Polizeidata-Mining-Geschichten ist generell halt sehr relevant und wird,
denke ich, auch in Zukunft dazu führen, dass man das auch in solchen Argumentationen benutzen kann.
Alright, so jetzt haben wir mit unseren großen Dingern durch.
Jetzt haben wir noch ein paar Kurz-Nachrichten für euch, die wir euch nicht vorenthalten.
Wo anfangen wir an?
Ja, also wir können ganz kurz TrustPID, wir erinnern uns, darüber haben wir
beide das letzte Mal gesprochen.
Wirklich? Oh Gott, TrustPID ist so das Ding, was ich immer wieder gleich wieder verdränge.
Genau, das P steht für Petze, wir erinnern uns.
Und das letzte Mal hatte ich darüber berichtet, dass die ganzen großen Telefonkonzerne
jetzt bei der EU-Kommission angeklopft haben und gesagt haben,
ja, wir wollen jetzt hier unsere eigene Werbeplattform machen.
Ist das eigentlich vereinbar mit kartellrechtlichen Fragen?
Und die EU-Kommission hat jetzt gesagt, jo, viel Spaß.
Mehr Werbung ist immer mehr gut.
Wie schön. Das habe ich mich total gesehnt auch.
Ja, die EU-Kommission ist ja auch irgendwo ein Dienstleister.
Und die versucht natürlich, alle Wünsche zu berücksichtigen.
Sowohl für die Leute, die pöbeln, als auch für die Leute, die sich nach Werbung sehen.
Dann vielleicht noch eine weitere Sache, die ich angesprochen hatte.
Wir hatten ja relativ viel über Contentmoderation gesprochen und auch über die
Situation, oder die prekären Situationen, in denen einige Contentmoderatoren arbeiten müssen.
Und es findet jetzt ein Contentmoderation oder ein Contentmoderator Summit statt,
organisiert von der Ver.di.
Und da wird es halt auch ganz wesentlich darum gehen, wie man sich als Content-Moderatorin
in Gewerkschaften organisieren kann und dementsprechend natürlich auch seine
Rechte einfordern kann.
Es ist eine nicht öffentliche Veranstaltung, aber es gibt einiges an Material
und Berichten dazu, also wen das interessiert, kann da ja mal vorbeischauen.
Genau, Link in den Show-Notes.
So, kommen wir langsam wieder zum Ende. Es ist ja mal gar nicht so einfach,
nicht depressiv zu werden mit den ganzen Nachrichten, die man hat,
auch wenn es jetzt ab und zu mal ein paar gute Nachrichten dazu gegeben hat.
Mittlerweile fällt das ja sogar den Suchmaschinen schwer.
Jetzt haben wir auch noch unseren AI-Block.
Das gehört ja heute dazu.
Nur für dich, Tim. Für mich? Du bist auf dieses Werbeversprechen reingefallen.
Was?
Deswegen müssen wir immer um AI reden am Ende. Findest du?
Also ich zahle noch keine 20 Dollar im Monat, um auf Chat-GPT zugreifen zu dürfen.
Und ich habe Chat-GPT noch nie benutzt.
Echt nicht? Nee. Och das kann man schon mal machen. Das ist eigentlich ganz lustig.
Ja, ich weiß.
Stell dir mal vor, du müsstest jetzt eine Rede im EU-Parlament halten.
Na ja, das könnte dir helfen. Vielleicht den Kontext dazu erläutern.
Also ich glaube nicht, nicht nur stell dir vor, du müsstest eine Rede im EU-Parlament
halten, sondern stell dir vor, du müsstest eine Rede im EU-Parlament halten
und möchtest es für die Verwaltung und die Übersetzer möglichst unangenehm gestalten.
Genau, hat nämlich einer gemacht und dann das Ganze irgendwie von Chat-GPT im
Shakespeare-Style sozusagen generieren lassen. Fand ich jetzt zwar nicht besonders
überzeugend, aber war auf jeden Fall eine lustige Idee.
Gibt ja schon ein paar Leute, die das benutzt haben auch für so Anfragen und so weiter.
Aber sehr viel interessanter ist, dass irgendwie das tolle Jet-GPT ja unter
anderem auch von Microsoft finanziert wird und jetzt in Bing eingebaut worden ist.
Und der Versuch ist allerdings offensichtlich ein bisschen fehlgeschlagen,
wenn man sich das so anschaut.
Die ersten Berichte, da hatte Bing doch so einige Probleme mit den Anfragen
der User irgendwie mitzuhalten. wirklich bemerkenswert.
Ja und vor allen Dingen, so Gaslighted ist auch sein User, wenn man anfängt
darüber zu diskutieren, welches Jahr wir eigentlich gerade haben.
Das ist echt so geil. Ja, könnte man sagen, wo der Film läuft irgendwie dieses Jahr.
Und dann so, ja, in diesem Jahr läuft der irgendwie nicht, weil der ist ja noch
gar nicht angelaufen. ging um den neuen Avatar-Film.
Und irgendwie war die Suchmaschine nicht davon zu überzeugen,
dass wir uns am Anfang 22 befinden. Selbst wenn du es darauf hingewiesen hast,
so ja, nee, ist aber schon 2023.
Dann hat er gesagt, das stimmt nicht.
Kommen wir nicht so, kommen wir nicht so, du hast wohl kein Vertrauen in mich
und so weiter. Also es wird dich echt erstaunlich.
Was hast du alles so für interessante Querschläge gemacht. Wir verlinken da
mal so ein Tweet mit so ein paar Screenshots von diesen Kommunikationen. Das ist echt großartig.
Aber es ist wirklich interessant, dass es sogar den Leuten gelungen ist,
irgendwie diese Suchmaschine in so einen Depressionsmodus zu versetzen,
wo sich dann irgendwie die Maschine irgendwie selber fragt, warum sie denn das
eigentlich tut, was sie macht.
Das ist alles so ein bisschen, also wenn einer wirklich recht gehabt hat,
was so die Zukunft betrifft, dann ist es ja eigentlich Stanley Kubrick.
Bin ich dafür zu jung vielleicht?
Eigentlich nicht, weil ich finde, Stanley Kubrick sollte man schon im Kindergarten
kennenlernen, aber meistens findet es dann später statt.
Aber Stanley Kubrick ist einfach der größte Filmregisseur aller Zeiten.
Unter anderem hat er eben das epischste Science-Fiction-Werk aller Zeiten gemacht, nämlich 2001.
In 2001 ist alles drin, was du wissen musst über die Zukunft.
Also da liegen iPads rum und so. Das ist irre.
Und aber auch so diese moderne Kommunikation, diese dialogische Kommunikation
mit künstlichen Intelligenzen spielt in diesem Film eine zentrale Rolle.
Da gibt es dann diesen tollen Raumschiffcomputer HAL 9000.
Und der Dialog des Protagonisten von 2001 mit diesem Computer ist sozusagen
das, was man auf jeden Fall mal gesehen haben muss.
Also da kann ich dir nur zu raten, da mal einen gemütlichen Abend zu starten
und 2001 muss man definitiv gesehen haben, weil dann weiß man eigentlich alles,
was man über künstliche Intelligenz wissen muss.
Vielleicht sollte ich das mal einigen EU Kommissaren empfehlen oder meinst du
das ist eine schlechte Idee?
Das ist eine hervorragende Idee. Man kann generell alle Filme von Stanley Kubrick empfehlen,
weil das halt so ein Typ ist, der hat ja nicht viele Filme gemacht,
aber er hat irgendwie erstmal nahezu kein Genre zweimal angefasst.
Also er hat sozusagen in jedem Genre mal einen Film abgeliefert und es ist eigentlich
in jedem Genre immer einer der besten, wenn nicht der beste.
Und das wird schon was heißen.
Das müsste man mal in Software oder Internet-Services hinkriegen.
Gut, dann kommen wir jetzt zu den Terminen. Möchtest du heute singen oder gehen wir mit der normalen?
Ich will das einfach nur vorlesen.
Ich will nicht singen. Genau, wir wollten euch noch zwei Termine hinweisen.
Einer ist bald und einer nicht. Und zwar geht es los hier mit Easter Hack.
Das ist nämlich so eine CCC-Veranstaltung, die gibt es jetzt mal wieder, endlich.
Haben wir glaube ich auch schon mal darauf hingewiesen und wir haben glaube
ich in jeder Sendung darauf hingewiesen seit drei Wochen.
Der findet in Hamburg statt, an Ostern. Das ist der 7. bis 10.
April und es gibt jetzt Tickets. Der erste Ticket-Click-Termin war gestern und
die Tickets waren ratzfatz alle weg.
Und es gibt noch zwei weitere am 24.02. um 08.00 Uhr.
18 Uhr und am 4.3. um 10 Uhr.
Also es lohnt sich sich einen Wecker zu stellen und schnell zu klicken.
Genau, ihr müsst allerdings vorher euch eine Bund-ID einrichten und das würde
ich euch dazu raten, dass ihr ja schon mal vorher ein Älterzentifikat beantragt,
weil dann geht das halt auch schneller.
Genau.
Wir wollen ja dafür sorgen, dass die Tickets dann auch gleichmäßig verteilt
werden und dass auch wirklich nur Berechtigte das bekommen. Ganz wichtig.
So, wenn das alles nichts wird, dann könnt ihr euch ja schon mal was für den Sommer aufschreiben.
Die unhackbar macht ein Event, was letztes Jahr auch schon stattgefunden hat,
nämlich hack an der Ruhr. Und das ist vom 16.6. bis 18.6.
Sie schreiben, wie schon im letzten Jahr, wenn wir das Event in der Heidekneipe
und der angegliederten Schütznale in Schwerte steigen lassen,
wer gerne übernachten möchte, hat wieder die Möglichkeit, ein Bett in dem Naturfreundehaus zu ergattern.
Zelten wird auch wieder möglich sein. Wir versuchen, Stellplätze für Camper zu organisieren.
Freut euch auf Amateurfunk Spaß mit Bambusstangen und vieles mehr.
Natürlich wird auch viel Zeit sein, um sich mit anderen auszutauschen oder um
Spaß am Gerät zu haben. Bambusstangen.
Jetzt frage ich mich, ob die der Pandas haben.
Ich hatte auch so gerade ein paar Assoziationen, aber das lassen wir jetzt einfach mal offen.
Meine Lieblings Pandas sind rote Pandas, also vielleicht habe ich eine Chance.
Ist das nicht dieser Firefox oder verwechsel ich da gerade irgendwas?
Also ich glaube der Firefox ist ein Fuchs.
Der Firefox ist ein Fuchs?
Nee, der Firefox.
Na ja, ich glaube schon.
Aber ein roter Panda sieht... Ist das ein roter Panda? Ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube es ist wirklich einfach ein Fuchs.
Du möchtest gerne, dass es ein Fuchs ist sozusagen.
Also weißt du, Tim, du weißt zwar alles, aber ich habe immer recht.
Achso. Nee, Firefox scheint wirklich nur ein Browser zu sein,
wenn ich das hier richtig sehe. Ich dachte das wäre...
Naja und wenn du dir die alten Logos ansiehst, dann sieht das sehr fuchsig aus.
Ich weiß nicht ob du weißt wie ein roter Panda aussieht, aber die sehen sehr viel süßer aus.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Toll aus. Ein roter Panda sind einfach die besten Tiere.
Dann müsstest du mal einen Browser vongeben, den würde ich benutzen.
Vielleicht ist das jetzt der neue User-Friendliber unser. Nichts, no offense Firefox.
Gut, die Sendung ist schon lang genug. Khaleesi, vielen Dank und vielen Dank
fürs Zuhören, mein Lieben da draußen.
Und mal gucken. Nächste Woche geht es irgendwie wieder weiter.
Dann schauen wir mal, ob Linus wieder da ist oder ob er noch ein bisschen Zeit braucht.
Also, Also, wir grüßen, bis bald. Ciao!
Bis bald!